oh this update to stream labs is
nice oh my god are we live already we
live i love how
how much better this one works firm for
us that we're live we're not even on
prime we're just on regular old stream
labs how are you guys doing today happy
belated thanksgiving happy black
friday hmm holiday you celebrate is that
a holiday people celebrate
black friday i i used to go out in the
wee hours of the morning and sh
and just you know go out for the chaos
uh
just to do it just to kind of soak the
energy up but but nah i think
i do not think we should deem this a
legitimate holiday that kind of feels
bad in my soul
okay looks like we're live hey everyone
how you guys doing
i hope you guys if whoever celebrates um
in uh whoever celebrates thanksgiving i
hope you had a good
thanksgiving holiday yeah who do we see
in the chat so far we got mark leach
already with the first super chat thanks
bud
robert estrada bradley blitzeau
i mean i guess this is an unusual time
for us to go live stream usually it's
like
5 p.m on a saturday so this is like a
little bit earlier
that's right i'm matching the purple
that's why i turned my spider-man hat
around i like
i like the match-up thing yeah thank you
to everyone who's congratulating me on
the engagement that means a lot
um i only did it to boost my credibility
it's branding
that's what i'm doing it's all branding
you know repaint my image
now everyone's like we got to support
that movie he announced because he's got
a family just exactly yeah
it's all brandy all manipulation
um olivia's just a hired actress yeah
she's out here
yep this is the character we invented uh
yeah okay
so i just wanted to have a fun one today
a nice relaxing
live stream thank you to everyone for
the congratulations again
really means a lot and uh let's see
what's the first comment that i oh
there's a lot of congratulations
i should have expected that because you
guys are so kind and so considerate
thank you so much you guys are beautiful
all right uh
we'll get to any super chats that come
in but of course grogu
uh i see i i would love to talk about
mandalorian
but i'm afraid there's some people who
if there's the rare chance that
someone's here
and they're like i haven't seen it yet
and i'm watching your stream first
yeah i don't want to take that chance
yeah i don't want to
dignify anything that could spoil stuff
the mandalorian season 2 episode 5
reaction should be up tomorrow and it's
one it's if not the best one of the best
episodes the mandalorian has done so far
it's pretty it's pretty [ __ ]
incredible it was a lot of fun
i was really uh i was really blown away
by it and
i i even got a little misty-eyed at the
end you might my cat i don't know
sometimes the camera doesn't pick it up
i hope it does hope it gets his little
tear in the i gotta get little pepper
lights
just to catch your tears blue crafter
all right this question will answer some
questions but thank you for everyone
who's contributing to the super chats
promise we'll get to them
uh sooner rather than later um clifford
the big red dog teaser have you
have you seen that teaser i have that
20-second teaser yes i have
how [ __ ] disturbing was that [ __ ]
they
i you know there are a lot goes wrong in
the pursuit of making things look
realistic or like they could occur in
nature and yeah the
i admire that they went for what a
realistic shade of red
might look like but yes it does look
like he's just covered in blood
oh yes it looks disturbing it looks like
cujo man
i i was not impressed with that at all
and because it's
not a super stylized dog it just looks
like a big
puppy who murdered someone it's like
kind of exactly yeah he looks
almost right yeah and and that makes it
worse
it makes it more disturbing ah thank you
everyone
who's coming in just to say
congratulations i really appreciate it
haven't seen the liberator yet
um of course we think of course we think
the new batman movie will be good it's
matt reeves
come on have you seen our coverage of
course we think it's going to be good
that's an easy question
we're both drinking mango and nissa i'm
on a white claw though he's on a truly
i'm on a truly yeah
yeah because he's a more honest guy i
played the first force on leash game i
thought that was pretty rad
um i i it's so long ago that was the one
that i played i played that one on wii i
think that was the first
star wars game i ever actually completed
the first one
you pretend you have a lightsaber with
the wii controllers oh yeah
i never actually got to do that the only
the one i got
first that i actually borrowed from our
old friend elsie and then
that was the one i beat was the one for
n64 where you get to play as
dash rendar yeah which was a pretty s
you know for its limitations i thought
it was pretty sweet but uh do we think
screen
five will be any good well i would tell
you that i have a lot of faith that's
gonna be good
i really love the movie ready or not
i've read the they recently put out an
interview where they
finally like really talked about the
prep process for this
and i have faith it'll be good i'm not
the biggest fan of scream 4
and uh scream 3 either even though
scream is my favorite horror movie of
all time
i think i think stream 5 will be all
right i hope so i have faith in the
people involved
my main concern is just that january
14th release date they claimed or
whatever
yes cause i was like for screen like
there was a lot of
argument for like yeah throw something
cool and especially like horror in those
winter months where there's not a lot
obviously blumhouse has success with
that but i feel like some like scream to
me feels like you want that
august september october somewhere like
right by halloween
or the summer but i don't know yes
that's the only thing that has me
worried otherwise i'm excited to see
what they come up with
and i've seen a couple of comments come
in here uh about
the mandalorian but people who haven't
seen it yet yes i will not blame you
if you abandon this stream to go watch
that episode
yeah if you haven't seen it yet if you
want my quick thoughts on it it's near
perfect
it's like i'm not sure if i rank it as
perfect but it's pretty much near
perfect
so i would not blame you if you're like
i gotta watch this episode right now or
i gotta catch up
and watch it i'm just thinking of images
from it in my mind and kind of wishing
we were just watching it
all together right now patrick
appreciate it shouts out to the
philippines appreciate you being here
sabrina thank you so much oh deadpool i
can see you in the chat right now we can
see we're looking that's all we're
answering we haven't gone to the super
chat so we're going to get there in just
a minute happy late
thanksgiving thank you sabrina thank you
to everyone who's contributing to the
super chat we also have stream labs open
right now so thank you
uh but right now in the description if
you want to access that
what do we think about i love you know
what do we think about the new justice
league movie have you
if sometimes people ask questions in
these chats these streams
where i'm like have you not been
watching videos we've been putting out
or you just want reaffirmation god damn
it
the next course is of course we think
it's going to be awesome i mean i'm
especially excited for it the title of
the next
video related to that will just be we
think this will be awesome
yeah um yeah yeah i mean even even i'm
looking forward to it i i think it'll at
least be a captivating moment no matter
what i think it'll have some of the ups
and downs that any zack snyder joint in
full zack snyder
regalia will have but i think it'll be
gripping
nevertheless okay so we got mr creptious
in the chat if you guys have not
subscribed to mr crap just correction
hands down one of the best editors
killer editor
i've ever seen he is one of the best hey
when old time radio comes out i'm either
gonna have to
talk to you or nerd chronic about
editing a trailer if i'm able to have
that much power
some people forget i'm just the writer
on it you know i'm not you're trying to
absorb more and more power you're trying
to run away with the question
but if it happens you know um yeah
that'd be awesome alan constanza is
asking and then we'll we'll get to the
super chats in just a minute i promise
uh and thank you to everyone again who's
been congratulating me on the engagement
uh alan cassandra's asking what do you
think about godzilla versus kong coming
to hbo max something we haven't chimed
in on
this might sound it's not controversial
this might sound a little contradictory
you're gonna get canceled over this
opinion i'd be way
less willing to like there's something
about wonder woman 84 which i'm like of
course the first time i want to
experience this is on the theaters
but if it comes out on hbo max i'll
watch it
you know it's that kind of thing with it
uh with wonder woman it's a bummer but
i'm i'm totally content
at the same time of yeah i'll watch it
godzilla vs kong
i'm like that movie's meant for the
theater that's that's
that's i mean it would be huge on hbo
max but it's meant for the theaters
wait that one wait i didn't much
care for godzilla king of the monsters
but what i did care for was the monsters
on like a three-story screen so yeah
it does seem like the worst movie to do
that to
because the big screen spectacle is like
i personally
they say tenant might come out this
winter on home video like i'm like
i might just not watch it and wait for
my opportunity to safely go to the
theater
whereas godzilla vs kong is like i would
cave and watch it if they put it there
but
i still feel like it's gonna do the
movie some slight
i would uh watch it at home tenant
because you could watch it with
subtitles you might understand what's
actually happening would have to do it
that way
would i not be missing out by not
experiencing the imax oh you totally
would
okay because that's the thing is like at
the imax like that's the problem with
you
but you might enjoy it more if you
watch it at home first and then get to
behold
that way you can understand it on
subtitles and then you get to just
immerse your visuals because i mean
almost every nolan there's rarely
the nolan movies on imax i usually watch
it on imax on my second or third viewing
and it actually creates an appreciation
level when you when you're able to
it's like we saw the dark knight you can
you can feel like the difference you
really
can experience the difference with imax
versus
okay the other one i like that actually
i i did not know that
actually that i thought you saw like
every one of his films imax first
no dunkirk we saw together the second
time dark knight dark knight rises
that's all the buildings he's done right
those three those the important ones
yes mandalorian will come out tomorrow
we do got some super chats i don't like
people have been contributing the last
10 minutes uh we only got a few so but i
want to make sure that we
that we honor whoever is showing their
support that way i mean yes
yes very much appreciate it we want to
make you feel as appreciated as you make
us feel especially
thanksgiving my fiance is relaxing right
now it's so strange it still hasn't like
it's so strange to just say it now
because yeah now you have to keep
putting the word in my fiance
yeah yeah that's that's that's fun enjoy
that
enjoy that process and then pronounce
every syllable
um okay let's see john can you load us
up please yes siree bobbering
time we'll take another question over
here yeah hey whip sir it's okay for
being late
let's see here oh is that a good size
let's go one one bigger there john just
setting us up so we can show your guys's
super chat's on screen right
and november 27th i have a very relaxed
approach today very relaxed approach
yeah mark leech all right we're ready to
oh
it's over here now i haven't seen the
widest kids you know no
i st i haven't seen much of the show
however
me and trevor moore were once in line i
was behind him at midnight in san diego
at my first uh full-length comic-con and
we were both denied the sale of alcohol
because in san diego they don't sell it
past midnight i would still say my
favorite movie soundtracks the dark
knight just throwing that out there
really quick
ooh that's a good old choice but let's
pack the block is pretty rad
i mean my favorite movie soundtrack i'm
talking about original score would be
dark knight my favorite soundtrack is
easily
drive there's like no question about it
undoubtedly
yeah yeah yeah john would you hang out
with a republican would i hang out with
a republican
i mean we know republicans yeah i'm
capable you know what this is
of hanging with people who don't agree
with me
side question thanks anisa for that and
thank you everyone's congratulating me
who's the first question mark leach our
first super chat of the day i appreciate
it buddy hey buddy
um hey you guys hope you're well what
film
had you been hyped to watch just to be
completely let down by
one of mine was the lovely bones amazing
book oh what a great question oh boy
easy easy actually i'm surprised it came
to me so easily
um x-men origins wolverine
that was a day we got uh i was cooking
hot dogs that was my profession at the
time i called professionals my
profession that was my career
the hot dog cook man uh if you live in
los angeles north hollywood vicious dogs
greggy veggie
still on the menu let's go there
sometimes tasty so anyway
uh yeah i i went to uh we we got tickets
to see x-men origins wolverine oh my
co-worker
no was she there i don't know jessica no
she helped she helped
help with your did my hair to look like
wolverine we went there
waited in line this is before there was
reserved seating
we waited in line for a long time the
trailers
looked so cool that is like a great
example
of a terrible trailer the great trailer
is
a terrible movie and that was an
a major letdown a lot of people try like
ask like what's the worst x-men movie to
me
and before people like chime in and ask
that i'll just say to me it's origins
wolverine i
like last man's bad sure dark phoenix
bad shirt but
wolverine origins just boring so
boring and silly at the same time yes so
that
for that one specifically i would say to
that question mark
leach i would say uh x-men origins
wolverine john what do you got
uh i have uh two either it's like
it's either batman v superman or
terminator salvation
okay because because because terminator
salvation was the same kind of thing i
remember that so i was wasn't the same
summer where we were sitting there going
man this trail
i could just watch this trailer has its
own little short film it looks so
amazing christian bale
he's gonna bring his gravitas to the
movie they're talking this great game
about like
exploring the war if you're outside the
course
yeah yeah it looks so cool and intense
that's the gatling going in
you're like oh my god this looks so
empty yeah you were like we're finally
going into the future
exploring the war john connor we're
gonna get like the fully developed
future
guy and then it was just like a boring
and
like lackluster thinly written action
movie that spoiled itself in the
trailers
yeah that's fair i mean i think it is
those two yeah i think it's easily
because bvs is one that's grown on me
especially with the ultimate edition
that became
i like the ultimate that one became like
that reached really good like pretty
good to really good for me right
so um like bvs grew i mean but salvation
and x-men origins wolverine they do not
get
better or suicide squad for that matter
but some people think dark physics is
the worst thing yes that republican
thing was like uh
it was an inside joke with anissa the
other day when i hopped on uh i hopped i
called the discord
oh wow uh we have a discord guys for the
patronage and uh i i
i hopped in last second eli
is this the first time we've seen your
name here eli appreciate the super chat
dude
um hey guys just want to support a
little bit and thank you for all the
amazing content you guys make
shots eli we should write a book about
you
and have it start denzel washington see
what we tear it tight
and then uh
tiffany hoffman thank you tiffany um all
right here we go am i here what are your
thoughts on the 50 shades of grey and
365
dni and after movies what are the 365
dni and after movies
uh i know 365 is that netflix
movie that was causing a ruckus a few
months ago
for being basically a porno
and it's got a similar setup that's
based around like a kinker bondage
relationship that is just kind of
abusive from my understanding of it i
haven't seen it but you know it's it's
oh wait no uh my fiance and i we we
skimmed that movie
how what was it like it was uh not a
there was another one that was
trending on tick tock a french film
climax
it might have been that um it was a
french film and then at the very
beginning of it is like a graphic
like you see everything go on
everything i was like i thought this was
a movie
and then we just we just skimmed it we
were like wow this is so how
how did netflix i mean i understand
there's like a kid setting in an adult
setting but this is like x-rated
settings right here yeah
way beyond the mpaa i mean what i would
say
is um uh let's see here uh
i would say that with the 50 shades of
grey movies
you know i actually kind of like
50 shades what's the third one called
freed okay darker is the one i like 50
shades darker is the one that i
kind of like that's the only one that
seems to be aware of what it is and is
having
genuine fun that's the only one the
first one
i think is really boring the the the
last one
i remember being in the theaters with
olivia and
we were just um so aroused we were
laughing our ass off in a pack theater
and
no one else was laughing and i was like
damn
there's a real movie fan base for this
i i thought we were all in on the joke
yeah that this is
terrible but i saw we were the only ones
laughing
when i went to the to the first one on
opening night i saw a grown man and his
groaner mother there to watch it
together yes
yes i did how funny it speaks to all
ages
and varieties i think those movies
are are fun in their own way although i
think they are a missed opportunity to
explore
i don't know a human sexuality and a fun
pulpy package
in a way that's actually fleshed out or
from the point of view of people who
actually know about
what the fantasy is yeah so i wish they
would open a door to i don't know
something more interesting there
but well let's see all right tyler uh
herrera oh see this is what you say in
every live stream
sorry if i butchered your name that's
what you guys said every live stream you
got to say that
you can't say sorry if i butchered your
name i did my best with your name
for your patience um so tyler
is asking us thank you tyler favorite
best performance in a tarantino movie
oh what a [ __ ] fantastic question
every tarantino cameo
i think a lot of people might go with
christoph waltz and
yes maybe in glorious or django
but i think more likely and glorious
excuse me
sorry if i butchered your name so yeah
the the uh the one that i my personal
favorite one and funny enough i was
thinking about this performance today
was i was hearing a podcast on like
actual strong female characters
and that wasn't a good air quote this
was my error quote
strong female character thriller dance
uh but my my favorite one it would have
to be
uh uma thurman and kill bill volume i
mean if you count the whole thing if you
want to play that game i would do that
uma thurman kill bill volume one and
volume two
because that performance has like all
the qualities i love in an action hero
because especially the time you get to
volume two or even early parts of volume
one you see
a woman who's very vulnerable she's very
human as much as she
has like super hero abilities in that
world of kill bill
and as much of a badass as she is you
know you really do get to see these
shades of her
that can fall uh the fall prey to
certain qualities within her
of of weakness and then from that
weakness she can find strength and
overcome and there's courage and there's
love there's a whole bunch of qualities
to that character
and to me i feel like that is not
everyone usually goes to like sarah
connor or ripley who are
amazing female performances and action
genres undoubtedly
but i really do think that uh uma
thurman and kill bill does not get
enough credit
as a female action star she was
incredible and
most likely yeah i would say she's my
favorite out of american action movies
she would be she's my favorite so i
would have to
give shouts out to uma thurman and kill
bill because i'm woke
oh look out now oh god that's what i say
look out look again the reason why i
must be
stuntman mike uh yeah uh i guess
now i will go uh that's a toughy uh i
guess
i don't agree with anything this
character stands for but honestly
i think leonardo dicaprio is is
incredible probably my second opinion
candy
calvin candy is like he's it's he's a
terrible terrible terrible character
played with
like complete magnetizing commitment and
like there's already such great
performances in django but
like his i really do feel like that's
the movie i wish dicaprio won an award
for because like he disappeared
so nasty yeah he was incredible and uh
shouts out runners up to uh i
i love the relationship between pangree
and uh and uh
mark forrester no robert robert forster
not the director not the director
or christopher robin robin yeah uh
they're
the scenes especially between the two of
them and jackie brown i i really really
love
i appreciate everyone who just hops in
here just to give a thank you uh
congratulations on the engagement like
derek mitchell right here
where'd he go thank you derek mitchell
how are you doing derek i hope things
have been said how are you doing derek
so how do you mother for me i hope
you're
you're i hope your charity live stream
went well
all right uh oh he did a charity live
stream that's why he's been gaming yeah
did it on the twitch thank you dude i
think right um
nissan and i do oh i don't have we've
seen your name before
what's your name what's your name
um nissan and i do he's asking uh john
you want to read this one i would love
to
in your opinion what is the most
underrated super
villain performance i personally love
that question thank you that's a great
one
i'm gonna have to think while you answer
i'd personally say michael shannon is
zod in man of steel also
congrats on the engagement and shouts
out from new zealand
thank you to new zealand super villain
performance
villain underrated one i mean you're
rated yeah
michael shannon as zod is a pretty damn
solid one
yeah uh i i just don't want to say the
one you said
though i want to come up with one that
is not said
maybe someone will just say it in the
comments right now
live stream chat and i might just steal
yours
uh but damn what is a good one what's an
underrated villain performance it's
gotta be a great one out there okay john
start listening to some random movies
and let's see
for grace is better i mean
i will go okay here's one then i think
that uh thomas hayden church
in spider-man 3 is one of the emotional
hearts of that movie he's responsible
for some of my favorite moments in that
movie and if it had just pared down to
his story
it might have act except for the retcon
with uncle ben it might have been a lot
better so i think that's a great
performance that goes over there
just said it
you know what i would say yeah jonathan
will i'm going to steal yours here i'm
stealing his
uh willem dafoe's green goblin for some
reason i feel like
it kind of just flies under the radar
when we're talking about super villain
performances but he captured
that he knew that that could have easily
gone wrong
oh yeah it is a hammed up performance
it's willem dafoe
totally having a blast and he's also
scary and it's it's funny how like the
green goblin
he when he does that expression in the
mirror when he's smiling and talking to
himself
this very vulnerable scene and that's a
that's a that's a character
especially when he is just norman
osborne having that conversation with
himself in the mirror
that's a vulnerable moment right there
and i thought he captured that well
and when he does that smile and how the
green goblin's face
he looks like willem dafoe's face yeah
and the fact too that you actually
care about him and his relationship to
peter as a father
figure you know like you want their
relationship to be okay
also um i mean a lot of people have been
saying this in the chat and it's a
hundred percent true
cameron monahan in gotham as and i do
think that would qualify a super villain
you know if we were talking heath
ledger i wouldn't say that's a super
villain um he's a the villain but he's
not
a super uh but definitely if you've seen
gotham
it's like impossible yeah it comes back
from the dead so
there's that that uh perform cameron
monahan plays
he he essentially plays three different
jokers
if you've seen the series from beginning
to the very final episode
he plays three different types of jokers
throughout
and i'm i i still feel like jerome would
be my favorite one because the other one
i think is
man i've seen the whole show jeremiah is
the other one but jerome
specifically was that that's one where
you're like man he really should be in
the movies
like cameron monahan and that uh he
should be in there and speaking as
cameron monahan
i want him to appear as cal in the
mandalorian he would be perfect i think
it would be awesome if you showed up in
there
yeah i think homelander and i think
homelander is uh
he's not an underrated supervillain i
think he's no he's the
highest on top right now yeah more
more talked about than any of the boys
golly adam lanza thank you so much adam
and thanks for that question issa that
was a fun one
adam lanza he's saying congrats on the
engagement thank you so much
do you think a good idea for a film
would be a youtuber internet person
being stalked by an obsessive fan
hasn't that been done ah versions of
this have been done yeah i mean
most recently with john travolta and
devin sawa what if there was a horror
movie where the uber
driver
i mean i think you could do kind of like
a joker-esque but
more heightened like a more of like an
american
psycho type of movie about youtubers
yeah someone who is like an
insane narcissist in their mindset and
then it's obsessed with like
comments and having to deal with the
hate and the kind of personality they
put on
in front of the camera versus who they
are when the camera's not rolling
because so much of youtube is like your
you know you're you're you're presenting
yourself
like and john talking and you're
conducting your energy in different
directions for different reasons
but you know most people and sometimes
ourselves included we might
feel like there's a different energy
when the camera's not rolling and
we're fairly in the same mood we were
when the camera started rolling
but that could be a lie oh the illusion
is breaking
fourth wall means nothing that's why i'm
thinking uh you could do kind of like
more of a character study of
the influencer i hate i really haven't
that word has never grown on me
or any fluency i think you could do that
or
one of those like really uh like limited
scale movies where it's like this one
crazed fan breaks into the guys houses
just two people the whole time
uh but i think your idea is more
interesting that would be like a
character study of someone who's like
really like that loses sight of
themselves how does this guy's channel
get so many views he does nothing
yeah i put so much effort into my
editing i mean i wrote a
i wrote a a a pilot for something that i
was thinking of
trying to get off the ground um called
in between takes that was about
like a uh uh kids said no in between
take not homeschool actors
oh in between takes about uh like uh
youtuber lifestyle but in like a satire
heightened way yeah
it's like a sketch comedy or something
where every week they're trying to do
something new to save the channel
cameron renfro thank you so much for
being here cameron appreciate the super
chat dude
and uh let's see here what do you guys
think of silver surfer the herald of
galactus being next avenger being next
being the next avenger movie i don't
know if you wanted a premier
silver surfer immediately in the next
avengers movie but i wouldn't mind if in
one of the next phase four movies
whether it be guardians of the galaxy
or doctor i feel like his appearance
because i
did read um the infinity war graphic
novel
and the work that he has to do
with they have they have to do with
dr strange in there i feel like it would
be kind of a cool since we didn't get
that in the infinity war movie i
personally maybe maybe not multiverse to
madness but i wouldn't mind
reserving their debut because i know
people will probably say silver surfer
wait for that fantastic four movie
but i wouldn't mind reserving their
debut for a doctor strange movie just so
we can have
that but maybe maybe in the next
avengers movie is when you would get
that the whole team up with dr strange
galactus uh dr strange silver surfer you
know having them
team up um to take down the next big
baddie would be in that one but
personally i would uh i would want it to
be in a dr strange film
and yes we did watch mandalorian episode
tomorrow
check that pin comment yeah in pencil
pan gets my youtube idea
misery like obsessed fan kind of like
that that could work yeah yeah yeah i
mean that was the original idea that
could work
it could it could but john what do you
think a silver surfer
i think i mean keanu reeves will play
him and ghost rider
and the next wolf and the blacks
wolverines everyone's gonna be keanu
reeves
uh that's what i want no i mean
there's so much coming to the next phase
that it
starts to a little bit feel to me like
oh everything's coming
in one of these next four movies yeah um
so yeah on the one hand i don't want to
get so lost in so many like galactus is
such a big deal of a villain to hail
that i mean it feels like an avengers
level event to me sure
i guess yeah i would want some kind of
prior uh
uh silver surfer interaction presence to
hail
this if it then leads to an avengers
team up with the silver surfer although
just thinking about like a new avengers
movie them
dealing with galactus with the help of
the silver surfer and doctor strange it
sounds like a lot of fun
so yeah i would be down for that
conceptually i
like this next set of phases especially
due to the way the world is right now
i'm
i it feels very kind of soft and
gelatinous in terms of its boundaries
and and what its structure
is so uh yeah at the moment i don't have
like as
even though they have their map charted
out it doesn't feel as
solid as it could and especially with
certain things moving around
so uh i mean we'll see yeah we'll see
but yeah i think it would be cool all
right uh ulysses
sedeno thank you so much buddy ulysses
come on let's get how many people how
many you guys know that song
lucy's by france hey luxo what you
talking about
25 miles oh well i'm bored
i'm bored which so bad it's good movie
deserves a reboot
oh fantastic that's a good one because
it's i mean try to make a good one out
of those and it's like that's not the
point anymore with that movie
yeah what would you be trying to achieve
with the remake
because so bad it's good is
unintentional when you
land there when you land it so bad it's
good
you like you don't set out for that when
you set out for that it doesn't work
i guess i guess you would have to then
go which one of these movies had a good
enough
concept at the core and perhaps good
enough
uh occasional plot mechanics to merit a
serious
attempt and i could think of two off the
dome i'm sure there are many more
uh i think you could do burdemic
okay you wanted to but i think a better
one would actually be plan nine for
outer space because that movie does have
like an alien plot where it's like
you know there's like an ecological bent
to things and the reason why they're
raising the dead
is partly about like how much we're
destroying and polluting the world so
so i think you could do something with
an actual budget
for that fair enough what's another so
bad it's
i mean i think plan 9 from outer space
is not a bad pick it's just the same
it's not the pig
it's just so bad it's good category is
such a fascinating one to me
because it completely redefines every
that movie that
falls into that category whatever movie
that is completely
the film is now redefined you know it's
like even if you go
you know what there's actually a lot of
potential to make a good movie out of
this the point of that film now has
completely altered now that it is so bad
it's good yeah it's like if you try to
remake rocky horror picture show or
something like that or the room like you
try to make a good version out of that
but that's not the point of the room
anymore so it's time to
oh what is and the concept of the room
isn't it there's gotta be one though
that would be a perfect pick
yeah to the point [ __ ] what would it be
i don't know i guess i guess you got the
best one in my opinion i don't know
maybe it's an
animated movie what's like a really
terrible anime justice
justin smith in the chat it says
starship
troopers but starship troopers is a
satire
it has a a comedic element in in
it knows what it's doing to a degree
it is campy that's a great
that might be a dc the best one that
might be because that blurs the line
between is this good because it's good
or is this good because it's silly good
oh matt c815 is not wanting it soju
enjoys saying
show girls and nisa i'm with you the
happening
i want the happiness you can make the
happening cool
am i wearing the hat to match your
microphone essentially yes
um but yeah not sure uh that's a good
question though man
yep yep yep okay
we really take our time on these
questions
jeter tv thank you so much gene
craigslist model book go check it out
craigslist
model what's up sending books to you
guys very soon oh well thank you
thank you sir for sending us his random
books
any random two books he's pulled from
the library i appreciate
some of these he's got a lending library
going with us uh let's see here
groot gaming 21. actually for the so bad
it's good maybe howard the duck maybe
marvel can finally do a good howard the
duck i'm
for it i say so and if they come kevin
feige says no this is not based on the
comics of howard the duck we are
remaking the movie
we're going off that blueprint is our
source
that's right the blueprint maybe
alistair's so bad it's good as cats um
groot gaming21 thank you man john and
your best groot impression
without saying the words i am groot this
is the first time groot is learning how
to speak words other than i am groot
read that did you guys
see that the actor that plays ned leeds
got super
ripped oh no bob goblin
perhaps oh gosh
wait who's in that leads again he's uh
the guy in the chair and uh
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah he's not genki
lee for some reason my mind was going to
needles from back to the future
oh yeah that's right he dropped a bunch
of weight and he's looking pretty fresh
that would be that would be fresh the
fact that there hasn't been a harry
osborn established in this version of
the mcu yet i think you could probably
but i mean wouldn't that kind of go
against ned's whole personality is going
to change
i mean but no i'm saying wouldn't that
go against we haven't skipped you we're
going
from bottom to top we're right here
completely beautiful bliss don't worry
we're going to get to you
um my john can't be a finger
you guys watch camp yet he's live right
now
watch this new movie by the way it's
good i'm in it
uh did you guys that's why it's good i
wouldn't mind seeing ned leads uh i
wouldn't mind seeing that actor
play uh be become harry osborn they
really did something different with it
the fact that they're doing the
multiverse of madness
and the fact that we've gotten two
versions of goblin already
within amazing spider-man the sam raimi
spider-man might as well mix it up and
see
and and also it might be more
impactful because it happened so quick
and amazing spider-man 2. it's just this
one movie
spider-man the first trilogy does build
to it but let's face it when james
franco
becomes him it's not bad he doesn't
really care about it this would be a
little bit more unexpected and probably
more devastating if ned leeds did be
coming because we're so
built into their rapport their
friendship
we care about them and ned leeds isn't
i'm forgetting the guy's name but
he's featured in the spider-man mazel
rallis game uh the what is genki thank
you lee
oh yeah he's featured in the spider-man
miles of rallies game and ned leeds is
definitely inspired from
that character so if you're able to like
get rid of that
leads in in the role that he plays
towards spider-man towards peter parker
and he becomes harry osborn it
actually could work to have more of an
emotional devastating effect that turn
that conflict so in some ways that could
work that i think that'd be pretty rad
sandwich
i think it would be heartbreaking lily
graham i love
i just saw your comment i love that one
thank you thank you
that's a great hashtag got talked go
talk to the higher ups about that one
thanks crew gaming beautiful bliss yeah
yeah
beautiful bliss in a list what is your
most
anticipated upcoming dc movies
number one is undoubtedly the bat the
batman
bring it to me now i want it right this
minute and then number two would be the
snyder cut
batman the snyder gun and uh
i mean wonderful the aircraft
wonder woman 1984 the suicide squad
yeah i mean i don't know this is about
black atom that i'm very skeptical about
i feel like this is gonna be so much of
the rock dwayne johnson and not enough
of
this is black adam yeah anything you
tell me shazam too i'm more excited for
shazam too than i am to see black adam
yeah
yeah likewise but because there's
one coming up isn't it yeah yeah well i
i
feel like i'm i mean there's always the
the like
looming possibility of aquaman two in
the trench i mean like the trench sounds
cool but i mean aquaman 2 is definitely
coming yeah
everyone happy about it there's nothing
controversial about the circumstances
yeah so there's that
um i uh i think we share the same list
yeah i think our list is exactly the
same most likely
yeah most likely um no there's an
aquaman to come i mean i i'm
i'm waiting to see i'm waiting to see uh
for some footage of that okay
on thank you favorite dcau film or tv
series i'm assuming i appreciate the
super chat thank you beautiful bliss by
the
way
but essay on i'm dc eu is what i'm
assuming you're referring to
my personal favorite dc eu anything
right now
uh even comparing to the movies
is actually doom patrol i you might have
heard me talk about this before but i
really do think doom patrol
is a severely underrated show there's
not another like and these it's so
beyond bizarre and so uh
just so character driven and so twisted
and
dark and it's hyper violent hypersexual
yet
incredibly nuanced and visually
wonderful
doom patrol is the best the best thing i
think dcu
currently has going in total
and i wish more people would watch it i
really do wish more
like i'm always afraid it's not gonna
get renewed poor people should watch
doom patrol that's just that's making me
want to start
doing what a patrol right now um
i mean are we saying dc animated
universe is that what that is
oh maybe the dc animated universe sure i
mean i i really love
i guess or is this like just anything
outside of the current dc
eu is it like the dc alternate universe
if that's what they're referring to
i would say my favorite dc au i mean
it's all connected at this point
yeah with all these inter-dimensional
crossovers i really liked uh
justice league apocalypse i thought that
was pretty [ __ ] fantastic
yeah well it's hard to be i was like oh
that's a justice league movie i'd want
to see
mask of the phantasm i i don't know i
mean i think it's hard to beat that i i
don't have the most up-to-date
uh like i mean for me it's hard to in
the animated realm beat that or the
animated batman series
but those are very sort of plea uh plebe
answers i mean i
okay eat spinach you can watch doom
patrol on hbo max
yeah and uh djo3 through t2 love you too
thank you buddy um but yeah guys watch
it
watch it and amelia clark would it be a
bad mirror just go throw that out there
sean davis
is it watchmen dc i'll go watch men
okay there you go that's even better
better answer
real but mikai mckee
take it away john looks like
joshua mikel who i know
absolutely who that is all right let's
look him up and i'll bring him to the
screen we're looking for joshua
or michael is that okay so in this super
chat right here
we got real mckee thank you by the way
i've heard this before
as a character as a character name yes
oh god what's like the best one that
looks like john
golly golly gee yeah pick you pick i'm
just gonna go with that one
there we go there he is you guys think
this looks like john
his name is joshua miguel i think he
looks like john
he's got a little bit more of like a of
a of a like lord of the rings elf thing
going on
yeah he's got a little bit slighter of a
face yeah
but he doesn't have his strong
features yeah he definitely has pointy
features this man
that's true guys mandalorian will be up
tomorrow appreciate it
uh josh guerrero
random topic thank you josh guerrero
sorry for butchering your name yeah
there's
a buzzer in it um okay no apparently a
lot of people don't agree that josh
joshua mikel looks like you oh well
that's i
also take mostly the hair both
no people people twin mechanic says
twins
we're twins definitely we are twins
random topic
flash and arrow series or luke cage and
daredevil series i mean i feel like i
generally know more about dc
just generally speaking i i know more
about dc
when if you're going to talk about these
shows right here
it's undoubtedly luke cage and daredevil
like flash i gave up on
i lost it i watched five seasons i think
i watched five full seasons and i
was like i've seen all of arrow i love
arrow
but there's some pretty weak seasons
there and but arrow ran for like eight
seasons so there's a big difference
there
where you can definitely have a chance
in dipping off in quality there's like
22 to 24 episodes per season
luke cage and daredevil to me is uh is
like
i'm hoping disney plus whatever marvel
shows they come out with
are able to top daredevil yeah but it
seems really hard because
man that dare that daredevil series gave
me everything and there's a campaign for
save daredevil coming out
and i'm gonna be putting out my hashtags
let me put on my social media because i
would
i undoubtedly want charlie caught i mean
just just daredevil alone takes the cake
for me if you're just to ask me what
between these four daredevil would
easily take the cake so
yeah i mean i i might read i definitely
read more
dc than i do marvel but i'm talking
about these four shows it's daredevil
man
it really is daredevil i've only read
one daredevil graphic novel which was
born again so
this is not like a bias towards him from
the show stared at well yeah
heck yeah and i really like luke cage
season two i thought that was a pretty
underrated season
too you heard it here first
people answer the question i i mean i
agree i haven't seen uh season three of
daredevil but i mean
having seen episodes of arrow and flash
uh secondhand while you were watching
them when we used to live together uh
ah yeah i mean like they i they didn't
look unappealing to me but they
definitely didn't look like they packed
quite the concentrated punch and i mean
there are elements of that
especially like the second season of
daredevil they do get a little off-road
but uh yeah just like the the craft and
the tonal
just punch of those two universes and i
like luke cage a lot too so yeah i'm
luke cage and daredevil definitely have
moments that i still think
back on uh and was incredibly gripped by
and that feel
like the caliber that like dc kind of
wants to go for and the fact that
they're like so kind of
contemplative and gritty but you know i
got a question for you i'm gonna throw
this out there in the chat right now
um what should i think of doing another
movie reaction
and i didn't know if it should be
i'm gonna throw this out there in the
chat right now you guys just start
naming which one
i'll go through the comments later to
see i might do a poll later but i want
to just get a gauge right now
for a movie reaction to put up on
youtube
i was choosing between constantine
because i actually haven't seen the
keanu reeves constantine movie i haven't
either i've never seen it and
i was also thinking uh new mutants
which one would give the most like if
new mutants is just like oh this is
boring that wouldn't make for a fun
reaction so
tell me which one tell me which one
and hbo's watchman was my favorite show
last year sound
off favorite show last year tied with
better call saul peter pacheco
thank you peter first off congrats on
the engagement thank you buddy really
appreciate that a lot
and good job on the john campbell
documentary guys
movie trailers love story out now
and also imagine if end game was the big
marvel coming out
due to covid oh can you imagine moving
that to streaming
wow that would that would a
break the internet and be cause of
rights okay
that would be bad oh yeah it would be
fun i appreciate that i appreciate
the shout outs to peter pacheco yeah
it's it's wow
a lot of a lot of us for constantine i'm
standing in the chat right now
peter is constantly contributing to our
live streams and i really do appreciate
it dude that means a lot and yeah
yeah i'm studying portuguese as we speak
my friend
yeah it's amazing if i look off screen
i'm reading duolingo okay just from
eyeballing this
i'm gonna see just from eyeballing it
what is
um what is uh okay
i mean it seems like the one to ch their
people are championing for his
undoubtably new mute uh constantly
i mean some people are saying new munis
because it would be fun to make fun of
new mutants but
it looks like constantine is the one
that it's like i've seen
obviously i've seen constantine the
animated ones matt ryan and then
constantine and the live-action stuff
like i really like his portrayal a lot
and i feel like they should keep him
they should keep him
uh like for movies and stuff that would
be great but
we're entering the have your cake and
eat it too arrow because all the
rumors i see right now is they're going
to get a both for some movies
constantine would actually be like a
good time
yeah i think i don't know i mean i've
always wanted to watch it personally
looks like a lot of fun
constantine might be the one i really do
want to check out though
and keanu i mean you know keanu i think
is always a recipe for a good time
i'm not sure about that question and
mart about uh count dooku turning the
dark side uh
disney plush show i don't really feel
like we need to see that show there's
not something i'm
truly interested i feel like we can kind
of do that to ourselves you could do
that in the book
uh maria hammond asking about the movie
i mean i i pretty much said everything
i'm allowed to say about it i mean what
i can't what are some fun things i can
give you the
the first one i wrote for it um because
it's an anthology story
the john actually uh he he read the
drafts that i i did on that and i really
uh i really appreciated his feedback
significantly on it and uh it did come
from joel harlow was the one who came up
with that idea
and um and then yeah like the
to the one story i wrote the other story
that's written were his idea and then we
wrote them and then the one that i
wrote called chicken heart is inspired
by a lights out radio classic
and i made a completely different
version for what that is nothing like
the old one like that was when i'm like
i'll take the main concept of the
chicken heart
that that's it and what did the have you
if you've ever listened to that one
but the plot is wildly different and the
way it ends and stuff like
it's not like that one at all and that
one i'm most excited to bring to life
just because i'm like
this is an adaptation of something and i
think that this could be like a really
cool way to adapt something you know
uh let's see i feel like everyone's
really championing mainly for
uh constantine awesome yeah everybody
loves keanu
uh let's see let's see here oh okay cool
cool leech i would love to see turbo kid
i have so many friends who love
that movie uh yeah i'm excited for
anything tom holland does i think tom
hall's an amazing actor yeah
hey jenna jenna's in the chat what's up
dear jenna where's there a course man i
don't see
harriet eric eric get a hold of okay
pull him out of the bar we have some
stream labs and some super chats that we
have to get through
too okay let's get to it let's do let's
get to it john load us up
we got it we're going on over
video got a dislike stream hey what are
we gonna do
it's still engagement apparently we
apparently um
offended someone oh i think the most
disgusting film i've ever seen alexis
is the ending the old boy no that's the
most disgusting one to me that one
easily just disturbed me for at least a
solid 24 hours
not bad i still gotta watch old boy uh
either human centipede two or three
probably
one of those and the first of our uh
stream labs over here uh is from bradley
bledsoe hey buddy
much love to you bradley says hey guys i
was curious as to what movie has the
best musical score and best
cinematography uh much love to you guys
and to the discord fam by the way
congratulations greg thank you bradley
thanks for being here bradley
dr bradley but apparently bradley just
left i don't know why
according to anissa bradley left too wow
wow guys
bradley well if in case you come back
i'll tell you
i was curious he says i was curious as
to what movie has the best musical score
to me i think the best
marriage of them honestly
this might i don't know if it's a weird
pick but i think it's one people won't
usually say i would say there will be
blood
huh i think that has the best marriage
of score
and cinematography i really like i
really like that movie a lot and i think
that was one of the best movies that
year and i
and for some reason when i think of
original score plus cinematography
they're
like i thought the the balance of all
that was phenomenal
for some reason my mind went there yeah
i guess these are all off the dome
questions
obviously no my answer might change
eventually uh
this is probably kind of a noob answer
but i feel like lord
lord of the rings is a pretty great
cross section of both because lord of
the rings has very
memorable and recognizable themes that
are specific but it also has a lot of
other textures
too it's scoring they pull in
vocalists from more contemporary arenas
in ways that are tasteful like annie
linux and stuff like that
and i mean crossed over with is this
like
the movie that has both the best score
and cinematography combined because yeah
i would say like the marriage the team
of it
because then yeah i would say that lord
of the rings then like every time i hear
one of those music cues i can see the
scene like it's so
much of a visual undertaking that is so
consistent and that grows across
three films i think you know as a
marriage of cinematography and
uh uh you know musical scoring that is
definitely one of the best
uh but there are so many great ones i
feel like any christopher nolan film
could probably
uh contend i don't know man i feel like
interstellars
like people love down zimmer score and
there's something for some reason i've
been thinking about interstellar even
before we went live and i was editing
for the mandalorian review
i would just say to john murphy
has been on my mind but just that
and i think interstellar's uh scores a
little bit
uh like he's just slamming the keyboard
or something
it's like i'm
[Music]
[Laughter]
but thank you bradley oh eric's at
dinner well
bye eric wow how how way to have a
family and have a dinner with them damn
eric
i see how it is all right john can you
read his question when i put my hair in
a ponytail
flav first off congrats greg on
your movie and engagement wish you well
in both of those journeys
thank you not just one second i'm
watching
alien for the first time with my you're
watching alien for your first time with
your buddy right now
like as we stream this didn't uh know
you guys will do a stream so early
hope i can still catch you after i'm
done okay so you might not even be here
to see this but either way
uh you know ripley great character i
hope you're enjoying alien
uh you know and she fights the predator
and it's great
so uh i hope that it's been a good
experience and that you get to catch a
little piece of this
um that's good man yeah i hope you're
enjoying it i'm
enjoying it it's the weekend so
thanksgiving weekend i'm surprised
anyone's here right now
honestly i thought people would be like
doing more of what you're doing right
now hanging out with other people so
i mean if you're here for the first time
or if you're here and you got nothing
else
going on i appreciate you being here
because i didn't expect many people to
be here today
no siree bob frankie j79
will disney drop black widow onto disney
plus to help
advance the cinematic universe also did
you guys
check out star wars gallery on disney
plus the episode featuring the
volume the crazy stage they shoot the
mandalorian on
that technology is a game changer uh
i i mean i will help advance the
cinematic universe
well thank you frankie jason now first
off for contributing here appreciate
that
i mean it's going to do whatever it's
going to do let's get like whatever the
plan originally was going to do
advance the cinematic universe i mean
that's kind of a different question do i
think it's a good idea
i feel like at this point maybe like it
doesn't seem to be getting any better
you'd be like in california where we're
at right now when it comes to because
you got i don't know if you guys saw my
video it was a joke video i'm not
that vehemently opposed to black widow
going out on his team
um but i i do think
that with the way covet has been like
right now they they
they like they were they've even
restricted more again uh
they used to be outdoor dining now we're
back on lockdown
we're streaming so we're yeah they were
take out
only yeah there have been a couple of
curfew it doesn't seem like a fully
consistent one but there have been a
couple curfews
there there are so i was just like i
don't know if it's gonna get any better
i mean the the talk about the vaccine
maybe will will change things
um but i mean it comes down to plus i'll
watch it plain and simple yeah
i mean it would be my preferable way to
watch it no no but will i watch it yeah
undoubtedly i mean i guess my main
question is
and and obviously would spoil the movie
to know but like
i don't know exactly what its impact is
going to be on the overall universe save
for maybe
giving us who will be the future black
widow persona
but yeah i don't know it almost feels
like at least as of its
overall consequence to the mcu it
doesn't really hurt to put it on
streaming i just yeah would be bummed
by that hey eric horseman in the chat
thanks eric
and jonathan would appreciate the
compliment on our collab with cosmic
wonder that was a really fun one yeah
took some chances to really throw that
man off
all right so let's see here thank you
frankie jason now christian alontay
um this is from streamlabs that we're
reading from by the way guys um
christian alontay hey guys with the
recent resurgence
in popularity of oh oh oh
we're way ahead of you season three we
are way ahead of you
three yeah i appreciate the question
christian
with the recent resurgence and
popularity of cobra kai since coming in
netflix would you guys consider both
doing reactions
when it comes on season three and
congratulations on everything greg
thank you buddy um yeah i mean season
one we covered here
there were problems with what happened
when we covered
wayne where we at wayne which is a
youtube original
which we had permission to cover from
the team
but there was a miscommunication from
the team with someone else on their team
so then all our videos got blocked and
we were like well we're not going to
cover a cobra kai now
yeah and then uh because of how we had
it scheduled on patreon
i couldn't cover cobra kai season 2 with
john so he did all watch alongs for it
but undoubtedly you bet you're sweet
sweet ass christian
when it comes out on netflix we are
watching it oh yes that was the first
show i ever watched on my
phone like cobra kai season two that was
the first one i
and then i realized oh my god there's a
possibility i can enjoy watching a
series on my phone
like that that was so gripping season
two
yeah really excited for what they do
with season three
and i know we haven't reacted anything
from season three we're just waiting for
the official trailer
to come out yeah and or like a teaser
that gives like real new footage for
like a minute or two you know yeah
uh but yeah when season three of cobra
kai comes out not a doubt in the book
we're totally covering that
youtube undoubtedly very excited very
excited for more cobra guys
at the taekwondo studio that i used to
train at
um that's the in the first karate kid
movie and the third karate kid movie
when they go to an
actual dojo that was the taekwon that
that was the taekwondo studio i used to
train out of
dang you're a part of the history greece
on the wall
oh yeah yeah that's fun
and that made people go with the karate
kid trained here
maybe i should train here it's a great
vote of confidence even though it's a
different martial art i will train here
and having the credibility of being the
place where they actually shot yeah
exactly
you know actually lends the credence 100
i wonder how many dojos hung up pictures
of people from that movie after the fact
just to pull in more business
all right john let's do a speed round
some questions here in the chat speed
round when's the next diss track
dropping greg
the commander what diss track are we
talking about remember that like right
that little ryan right diss track you
dropped like way back oh jesus that was
ages ago oh my god
all right when's your diss track coming
i'm gonna you're one against
[ __ ] cosmic wonder winter yeah me and
warren
we're gonna go out which did you prefer
inception or tenet um oh inception
handsome
undoubtably inside and inception is just
mindfuckery enough but you can follow it
yeah some gorgeous visuals tenet is uh
lieutenant it was uh like mike my fiance
is so smart
she's so smart she was like
my experience with 10 and some of you
guys might have heard me say something
along those lines before
but my experience with it when watching
with her there were see like early on in
the movie
it was the best way i could sum up how
much she was able to understand and how
much i wasn't able to understand it
about 25 30 minutes into movie there's
this big there's this like action set
piece that happens
i won't say which one if you haven't
seen it right and then
this thing happens that's all tenet like
and then
and then olivia goes oh my god i think i
know what the twist is
and then i looked at her like i don't
even know what's happening right now
you know what the twist is you know an
hour or two
down the line like an hour and a half in
advance what the twit i don't even know
what's going on on screen at the moment
this is so confusing so yeah i mean i
i enjoyed it like there's something to
be said about it because
you know 10 it's a movie that i just
couldn't understand
like what the hell the movie was really
about and i had to annoyingly have her
whisper to me the whole time and because
of social distancing in the theaters
i was so happy because i had to have her
explain so much but after about
knowing about an hour and i was like i'm
not going to have her explain anything
more to me because i'm sure this is
tiresome for her and
this has been a commentary track every
time she's whispering something in my
ear the movie's saying more stuff that i
need to that she needs to pay attention
to to communicate to me i'm like i'll
just ask her when the movie's done
just ask you to recap the entirety of it
and the car ride back
and then we watched anaheim then we
watched new rockstars video the
breakdown that explains it
and then she had to keep pausing and
rewinding for me so she could
because i couldn't even keep up with new
rockstars breakdown of the movie
damn i am so just so excited to to not
understand this movie
uh sean davis i don't know who i would
want in the movie i mean ryan gosling's
always been my dream guy to work with
the real question i wouldn't mind
getting johnny depp for a role i don't
think we'll go for it
i wouldn't mind attempting to who would
you want him to play
do you have a role in mind even if you
can't talk uh
yeah there's one character in mind uh
and uh there's a specific one on the
live bait story that i wouldn't mind
but honestly i'm not just saying that
because of the whole justice for johnny
thing like i
i really i also want to cast amber her
everyone do it all
mel gibson there let's get louie ck
hey christie elia i want to get them all
and in the background of every scene
chappelle show is playing
oh yes siri uh conjuring three i like
the new spin that i got a question about
contract i love the new spin on what
they're doing with conjuring three of
how it kind of has this exorcism of
emily rose vibe
yeah and in my feed lawyer reacts to
exorcism of emily rhodes recently popped
up and i did want to check that
check that out who would you guys rather
date jessica rabbit or elastigirl
i'd rather date elastigirl i'll take
jessica rabbit because i was going
to anyway i feel like with elastigirl
you can do more stuff with her
that's true she does have an
extra human power of elasticity
or i'd just be grossed out the entire
time it's really
i think it really hinges on what that
looks like in in our reality
i think if i morphed into
someone's asking if would you rather
date elastigirl or jessica rabbit tony
lawrence
i think if i morphed into the animated
world
it's like when i was younger and i saw
indian in the cupboard i used to imagine
just shrinking down to a little like a
tiny little toy boy
making like a female doll having her
come to life and in the cupboard
turn it and the cupboard turn it they
come to life and then oh that's my new
girlfriend or something
so maybe if i went to the animated world
i would want a last girl
in the real life if there was a woman
who was like elastigirl i'd probably
just gross that
that's fair that's absolutely fair
that's just it man
but you know you gotta you gotta you
know learn to accept uh her
uh we gotta look at what the next
superman is ask about the supernatural
conventions we gotta look at which one
it is that uh
ash sent to us but most likely we will
be and uh
we'd usually do them at the beginning i
don't think we missed did we miss this
we must be getting a new okay then yeah
next month for sure we'll do it
for sure there were mandos and things
going on uh
daniel i i never remember the name of
the guy who record but i'll tell you
guys i'll give you guys a fun story
uh really quick before we continue the
super chats we got some super chats to
go through
um i didn't mention this in the video
but
uh like if you guys saw my video where i
proposed to olivia
there was i was actually waiting for i
at one point you could ask her i wait i
was telling her like man i wish
i wish people would just leave because
at first when we first got to the top of
the hill
and the ocean view there was like four
other people there and i
and i thought to myself okay eventually
they're gonna leave right because we
just got here
so they have to leave and we didn't see
anyone behind us on this trail
and i was just waiting it out waiting to
be alone and then these
and then more people just showed up and
it was getting to the point like we
gotta head back it's gonna get pitch
black soon so we gotta head back
and and then i realized i got no choice
but to do this in front of people so i
might as well try to like get someone to
take a photo and i went up to this
this group though a fox showed up it was
gorgeous a fox showed up
and everyone was just around it and
olivia loves the fox
hey she's a major animal lover and b um
you know she's recently played ghosts to
shima
and she you know fox means good luck or
something like that right what does the
[ __ ]
so then um so then she
uh casually tells a lot of weird side
it's true so
so then um there's this group of people
and then i went to a guy far away
because i knew i needed to whisper to
him
can you take a video i needed someone
far away who where olivia couldn't hear
me
excuse me sir so i went up to him
and i was like hey man didn't you take a
photo first yeah sure and then i
whispered
oh can you actually record i'm about to
i'm about to propose to her
and then and then he looked up at me
he's like huh
[Music]
to have seen that reaction and then i
said and i said you're my new best
friend
so he was so nervous so if you actually
listen if you have headphones on and you
watch that video
you could hear him telling his friends
because they had no idea
that's a wonderful story that truly is
that guy whoever you are i hope one day
you're like oh my god i reckon i hope
one day he comes across that footage
and goes i recorded that yeah that's me
i deserve some profits guys those guys
obviously don't know who the hell i was
you know um but that would that would be
funny heroes fan productions thanks for
being here yeah
some stock millionaire of the dark
knight well that's a real sophie's put
two together buddy there you go that
august
md that's what we gotta do all right
heading back over to the super chat
which oh man we got something we got a
lot we got to honor some super chats
oh my goodness gracious me you guys are
so generous peter protection
there we go all right ethan holgate is
next i really appreciate that
thank you guys it means a lot thank you
for making our halloween holiday weekend
extra day
it's always followed by some people did
think it was john record they just
assumed it was john um even though i'm
always winning yeah always not with us
they just fold me up at night and they
unplug me and they just he's the depre
and you me and dupree apparently usually
when we're done
doing our youtube and patreon stuff john
leaves it's plain simple
no i i leave but then i just sit outside
on the porch when can i come back
inside um it's cold out it's winter now
no whenever we refresh the super chats
and we're like oh my god there's so many
we haven't done
it it's also followed by uh like
insincere gratitude that you guys would
share your support that way seriously it
means a lot um
ethan holgate i had to congratulate on
your and get congrats
i gave you a translation are your
engagement correct love
the heart oh man i can't say this ethan
holgate constantly see you here on our
super chats your big support of the
channel and i really appreciate that
appreciate you
seriously thank you much love chill
level tv
favorite live action big budget disney
film
oh my god pirates of the caribbean the
curse of the black pearl oh boy that
he's hard to beat
ajrd to beat it's never gotten better i
mean some might say
jungle book but not pirates of the
caribbean wow
do you guys remember when i don't know
who was around i mean that was
follow the box office of when that came
out i didn't watch that movie till i
think the
fifth week it was out yeah and it was
still number one at the box office
and i was mesmerized yeah it's one of
those ones you've been hearing about for
weeks now and you go watch it you're
like wow that really is an amazing movie
well in that movie i think was that's
the at least the first three i think
were at a critical flash point in
in film technology where we didn't have
quite
enough cg to undertake a movie like that
without assuming that we're gonna build
a lot of stuff so like those first three
movies do
have the production values of like a
true
hollywood epic absolutely film and uh
yeah for for those reasons alone and
yeah especially the first one i would
say
it's really hard to beat and johnny
that's performance in that first one
everyone was jack sparrowing after that
oh my god
took the world by storm he was so
hilarious in that film
man the glory tastes so [ __ ] the
pinnacle of the glory days
i'm hoping he has enough residuals to
live off of
right foreign sure of it i mean are
those movies on
uh are they on disney plus i don't know
if they're on disney plus or not
i gotta imagine they are but i don't
know i would be
i guess i wouldn't be 100 surprised if
they weren't but i would be
surprised well let me ask you guys in
the comments what's your favorite live
action disney movie tell us tomorrowland
christina right back at you
uh thank you christina it means a lot
wait that's that's a really
that's really nice thank you two thumbs
up
to you thank you christina manuel
fernandez
manuel all right john take it away hey
guys i'm taking a class on the films of
alejano
alejandro inarritu uh alfonso cuaron and
guillermo del toro
who funny enough came up all three at
thanksgiving dinner last night how would
you rank them as directors and why
ooh ooh i i guess i would rank them in
two different
fashions i would rank them separately
for my enjoyment overall
and i guess in that respect i would go
del toro
uh quaron we might as well have spoken
at the exact
same time all right you want to do the
next part just simultaneously
i i really that is that is my order too
yeah um
in terms of like skill i feel like
inuritu really like
really pushes to do like difficult stuff
so i might
like on the technical end have to bump
him up because guillermo del toro can
get a little lost in his romantic
aspirations and whatnot um i think
alfonso corona is like perfectly right
in the center of them oh man but someone
mentioned sky high off a favorite disney
movie that's a great one
oh underrated underrated there should be
a tv show
um okay but in regards to this question
you know i actually might bump uh deltoi
i might put del toro second
i would probably say coron okay corone
did children of men
yeah and honestly that's like one of the
greatest [ __ ] movies of all time
that's fair absolutely uh my favorite
del toro movie
is pan's labyrinth
i really love the shape of water i do
and i thought he i thought he absolutely
deserved the oscar for it
but i don't know i might have to say i
i think i would i try a slight margin
this little edge i would give to corrupt
because alan and yuri he did revenant
revenant yeah bird man
yeah and corona did you do a mortise
cuaron did
the third harry potter i believe he did
a little princess he did gravity
he did and alejandra enrique and alfonso
chrome both loved the one shot
yes they did they love it so that's why
i think i sometimes get their films
confused not only does
my american brain
just getting lost when i see their names
because they both begin with a it's not
my fault
um inuritu always oh what were you gonna
say but i just think that uh i think in
in terms of the kind of films they make
they they can be kind of similar and i
wish i was more well-educated to
properly
be like here's exactly what they do
that's completely different because i'm
usually under the impression coron
directed birdman
my mind tends to go there yeah i see i
think i feel like the way i
differentiate the two of them is
it seems like ali honey alejandro and
inuritu
likes to to push uh like the
the i don't know it seems like birdman
the revenant those seems like very
challenging films to make and it's like
we're all natural light it seems like he
likes to really undergo
technical challenge i associate him with
a lot of
technical parts whereas cuaron he is
technical but i feel like he has
more of the heart spectrum fair enough
you know but that's just me
all right thank you didn't they like all
come up together as buds back in like
the the early film days
ian sotelo it's nice to see you again
hey instatell thank you what did you
think of patrick wilson singing can't
help falling in love by elvis
in the conjuring too did you also like
how the movie ended on a happy note
uh yeah i mean that was one of the most
amusing scenes that that i love a scene
that could easily go wrong
yeah that it could really go into this
is so
corny this is so cheesy this is not
clicking like it
easily could have gone there so i really
love that moment
and i do like the horror movies that
have a little bit of a sense
of wonder or fantasy element to it and
those are the ones that usually end on a
happier note
and said you know like i mean james bond
directed both insidious and conjuring
two
and you know let's face it that one has
a much more raw ending and the other
one's like oh that's nice
and i think for conjuring since so much
of the themes are about
family and connection yeah i think for
it to end on a happier note like that
actually works yeah it makes all the
sense i feel like is especially if
you're tying it to the relationship
between these two who
experienced various cases i feel like
that is an appropriate way to bring it
back to a
an uplifting note and uh and yeah i mean
i i
love when in any kind of movie i feel
like
silliness and play are parts of life
that are easy to overlook and especially
to kind of throw by the wayside in a
movie that's more dramatic or scary or
harsh or whatever
and a moment like that where he does a
little bit of an elvis impression and
there's humor there i thought yeah
bringing in a little bit of that play
actually sold a really nice
character bonding moment so yeah i love
that you know what i used to point out
about patrick wilson
before everyone really knew patrick
wilson's name
was that the guy who was either naked or
half naked
every movie he was in it got to apply i
think around aquaman literally the one
movie where i thought it was warren
tickets he's underwater
where i'm like she's naked he's
but that dude patrick wilson in almost
every movie he's either in his underwear
has his shirt off or is naked
everything i'd say there was a solid
point in his career where it was just
like that
every film that's how he auditions and
that's why he gets so many rules
i remember making that crack before we
saw lakeview terrace and then sure
enough
there's a scene where he's running with
his shirt off and i'm like in his
underwear this guy's
always half naked especially if he's
like a domestic character of any kind
he'll be running around in underwear at
some point
i think i was the only one who ever
noticed that you are
you are the guy who could patrick wilson
play in the mcu oh dude
wolverine mr fantastic mr fitzgerald i
mean he could beat it easily
yeah actually shouts out to spencer pop
culture podcast we talked a little bit
about that
i saw you in the chat anissa homegirl
what's up anissa take it away
john john house of a thousand corpses is
my favorite movie since i watched it now
i thought in my head it was not my cup
of tea sadly sorry john
just thought it uh thought too rushed
but still have to check out the devil's
rejects any more suggestions any horror
well i would say get on the devil's
rejects if you're a fan of the real
rejects that's the title that inspired
the
title of this channel it's inspired the
spirit of this year yeah you
[ __ ] rugby
i saw the devil's rejects before i saw a
house of a thousand corpses
and i had no idea i didn't even register
because i hadn't seen house of a
thousand corpses
that the devil's rejects was in fact a
sequel
of a thousand corpses and the devil's
rejects is
really done in a way where you don't
have to see house a thousand corpses
because not only
does it give you a refresher on who the
family is but
it also is just captured completely
different it like the first one is a
little bit more of that
campy in-your-face kind of vibe and the
devil's rejects it's a lot more
gritty handheld raw desert
it's a very icky grim yeah and i think
uh
devil's rejects is it easily rob
zombie's best movie
and uh i think that's actually worth
watching just even if you don't like
house of a thousand corpses it might be
an improvement they might be like
well because i way prefer it over a
house of a thousand and i i think you
might i would go check that out
and also just uh i would also champion
for this one the invitation i don't
think enough people watch that
invitation go watch the invitation and
uh go re-watch if you haven't seen it go
watch the others
i'm in a gothic mood right now go watch
the others
and actually it's also based on the turn
of the screw which
haunting a blind manor was so relevant
which one is better
they're very different of course mom i
am your child i'm your child i yeah
come on this is a good movie it's a good
movie
it's a good movie oh man that twisted
and the others
oh yeah
watch green room i'm just going to keep
shouting things out until we read derek
mitchell derek mitchell
derek favorite oh do you want to take it
yeah what is your favorite leo dicaprio
performance that's the only thing i do
for a dicaprio
yeah it's like a squid [ __ ] right here
with the squint so this is like his
little head turn
the camera is just like
what if you can go into a dream
that's i i'm loving this that's
watch his movies that's what he always
does when he's like serious intense like
wolf of wall street he's not like that
no
but when he was like seriously i think
when the movies when he doesn't really
know what he's uh what the film's about
um well i can
gather every [ __ ] my favorite
performance of him
is the departed that's my favorite like
his question is favorite dicaprio
performance i'll probably be blood
dialed with inception in a very close
second
uh it's it's uh departed and um
i mean for use probably django i'm
assuming yeah i'm trying to think of
what my runner-up would be
yeah it's definitely departed uh that's
a great
that's a terrific performance though
because i like dicaprio a lot
and then he came out of gangs in new
york but let's face everyone was talking
about daniel day lewis
he did aviator and for some reason that
was one of those
weird roles for me with dicaprio where
i'm like
i can tell he's giving it his all and i
feel like he's doing a really damn good
job
but for some reason i still just see
leonardo dicaprio and i don't see howard
hughes
that was he was trying to break the like
man barrier
moment yeah and uh blood diamond and
departed came out in the same year
and both like the one two punch of those
movies
it's like [ __ ] this guy's a man now yeah
he ain't pretty boy dicaprio anymore
this guy's a man and uh departed was the
one that did it
but like that yeah everything that he
does is like his dicaprio quirks
he's like hyperparanoid yeah super
intense guys
i really like him in shutter island
which is also a hyper paranoid intense
guy but i mean
you know not that it's the argue i don't
think a lot of people would choose it
but i think back on that movie a lot and
i i really think he anchors it really
really nicely
and there is a lot of it's weird it's
like that's one of i think martin score
says he's more like
fun and and wild films because it's
borrowing so much from like
you know the 50s tradition of horror but
yeah
i really love the way he anchors that
movie and when it descends into the
harshest and most affecting parts like
you know
it is pretty heavy and uh yeah i loved
his contribution to that and uh and and
sentimentally catch me if you can
uh yeah i agree with the sentimental
part there but i also do
think that uh wolf of wall street
is his breakfast performance oh yeah i
was thinking i was thinking about that
too
that's a pretty surprising role honestly
like it's he
he goes all out with just there's no
shame in like those
those sexual scenes especially like this
sex
when he's just on his face crawling and
drooling during
the quaaludes internally yeah like
there's
a candle in his butt yeah like there's
so
much wild stuff that he has to do in
that movie and play it off like a more
normal-ish guy you know less of a like
deep character descent that's obvious
yeah man he's pretty great and gilbert
grave is pretty awesome too
but thanks derek mitchell i mean for a
full one victor 983
thank you victor 93. yeah a lot of love
for dicaprio in here now i saw one
comment that said
i haven't seen basketball diaries justin
but listen one comment that said um
what'd they say that he plays the same
character in every movie and i don't
agree with that
i don't feel like he's the best at
transforming his voice or body language
necessarily
but i wouldn't say he plays the same
character like that when actors like
christian bale and day lewis really
rose to fame they really changed the
game for what it means to play different
characters
yeah because now fully disappear you
have to transform like a [ __ ]
yeah
but uh i don't think he plays the same i
think uh he
he does have differences they're just
not as apparent or obvious in the ways
of
like when christian bale would do it or
gary oldman changes or tom hardy
i want to remake face off with him and
tom cruise yeah dicaprio i think they
should do dwayne johnson and kevin hart
that would be great oh good victor 93
uh thank you victor have you guys seen
any swedish movies um
isn't let the right ones i think that's
the swedish left the right one in is one
of my favorite
horror movie i'd say it's a gothic
horror movie it's one of my favorite
horror movies
and easily my favorite vampire movie so
i would say let the ride one in i've
seen that one
and that's probably the only one i've
seen sorry
i think troll hunt no that's norwegian
damn
uh damn i don't know if i've seen i know
in
film school we watched some like
experimental stuff from all across the
world and i think sweden was
included in there but being that i have
not seen let the right one in in its
entirety
i'm not sh i couldn't say for certain
i feel like i have i feel like i've
probably seen some
foreign horror uh from there but
at the same time every example i come to
i'm like no that's dutch and that's
austria
oh yeah all these different areas that
are like kind of
nearby but not so but i'm definitely
gonna google
some great ones after this stream
actually anissa you asked us earlier in
this stream
can you recommend some horror movies let
the right one
in do that it's not that scary i'm not
going to be like it's a terrifying film
but it's it's a damn good movie and if
anyone in this stream
has seen let the right one in i hope you
can leave down a quick thought here
about what you thought of it that is a
beautiful film
oh yosh sorry mandy hell yeah new uh
who's next de niraj
ah niraj buddy yeah mirage you're the
lucky son of a [ __ ] you got a shout out
and the mandalorian reaction that's
going up manana
um movies you feel would have been
on a tv series that would make a really
good movie
i wouldn't mind like they're bringing
back dexter for an eight episode
series or eight to ten episode series
and i'm more under the impression of
you know if you did like a two and a
half hour dexter movie i'd be down for
that even if it was just a streaming
movie i think that would be enough
but we'll see i want a two-hour dexter's
laboratory movie
and i will accept nothing less than that
i'm trying to think if there any live
like usually when i see a live-action tv
series i'm like yes it was good that
this wasn't
contained to to a movie i think that we
said this in the review but i still this
often comes to mind as i i thought dr
sleep would have been made a much better
mini series oh yeah yeah we both thought
yeah if you've seen hill house or blind
manor you know exactly why
and i wonder if we haven't seen if we
hadn't seen hill house
if we would have had that same
impression yeah because watching dr
sleep
just made me think of a sped up version
of hill house exactly just with a lot of
the character side quests drawn out
yeah you know or take it out that's a
good question thanks niraj yeah
you guys have any pics you want to put
down in the comments uh
anissa oliva let's see here do you all
like
thank you anisa do you all like richard
linklater movies as a fellow texan he's
probably one of my favorite directors i
enjoy his movies a lot especially
boyhood
oh john this one's all you you
definitely see more richard link later
than i have so take it away buddy
yeah i haven't seen his entire
filmography and i haven't seen dazed and
confused which is arguably like
one of the biggest but i've seen several
of his movies and i really
like him as a filmmaker partly because
uh
he brings so much just i don't know
there's a very like human quality to the
way he makes movies there's a very
compassionate quality and it can exist
across
more uh naturalistic but experimental
stuff like boyhood that's very slice of
life or things like school of rock that
are
more heightened and fun and accessible
and so yeah i'm a big fan of his and
every time i see
something of his even if it's not like a
slam dunk i'm always like man i
appreciated what you were doing here so
yeah
i like richard link later a lot i don't
think i've ever seen a richard link
theater movie
really wait is school of rock him mm-hmm
yeah i've seen a scoop for sure like
that yeah yeah
it's school of rock that's the one
school of rock dazed and confused uh he
did he did a scanner darkly does
everybody want some him too
everybody wants oh i did see that
because that's a spiritual exception
i didn't realize originally because i
think that's a spiritual sequel or
something to dazed and confused if i'm
not mistaken
oh yeah my mind did not go there for
sure oh
actually really quick i want to give us
mcconaughey i want to go back to niraj
one that i think would make a great
movie is a rick and morty movie ah
that would be a yeah that would be cool
that'd be good to see what they do with
that format
and that time span yeah uh that would be
my one right there
oh bad news beers uh the original walter
matthau or is it the billy bob thornton
ones this is the billy bob thorgan one
uh that's i mean that's the one i've
seen
it's gotta be it's the one i've said
i've seen
pieces of the original when i was a
child and they're fragments but i'm
saying
that there is a ritual the richer link
better one is the billy bob thornton
yeah yes for some reason i was really
under the impression i haven't got i
forgot he made that
the link later made that uh aditha
near s thank you so much uh a horror fan
and a subscriber from india here what's
up
please do another top 10 horror movie
episode hey you know it's been a long
time since we've done that
love trick or treat anything new since
then that is coming to the list also
congrats to you and olivia
uh thank you so much first off i would
definitely and thank you kim wexler i
see you giving a lot of love there too
i would definitely add i think since
we've done that list
the ones because lists like that often
fluctuate sometimes
i feel like it put a video out there and
it's just the bible at that point it is
scriptures
so uh but i would definitely probably
add babadook here and hereditary onto
there
i think those are two films that my mind
often just
flashes to definitely bubbadoo and her
yeah hereditary like it's
i don't even have like a it's weird like
i don't even necessarily like
love that movie but i just have so much
respect for it it's so effective
true i feel like it's hard to leave off
a list like and i would say the
invitation as well invitationally the
invitation
like these are three movies that my my
mind you guys have any movies like that
where your mind just sort of wanders off
and just for some reason you keep
thinking about this one movie
for like a long period of time and
that's one of those moves those three
movies or three in my mind just
sometimes just hops too and i'm lost and
thought thinking about it i had that for
the dark knight for like seven years
and this and those three horror movies i
would definitely put in there if mandy
count i mean mandy is like a
hyper asterisk like many genres movie
but there's definitely horror in there
and that's one that i would add to a
list just for how surreal and
crazy it is yes yes uh
the naked gun remake what really uh
let's see that's him yep do it
anissa oliva are you all excited for
jensen eckles as
soldier boy in the boys
undoubtedly i am undoubtedly i think
that is such a great career move
on his and because he easily could have
been
in the position uh like i always talk
about that if you wanna start branching
out or
transitioning you gotta you gotta
transition you gotta take
steps some people try to do this like
[ __ ] major
swing and i don't think that usually
works for actors or directors
i feel like it's you got to build to it
you know i think shia labeouf did that
really well and robert pattinson
i think tried doing a pendulum swing and
that's why i wasn't panning out at first
but then eventually it did he just had
such perseverance
he did you know seriously but jensen
ackles i mean i think that's such a much
better decision than
i'm sure jared paddle like you will be
fine on walker texas ranger but i'm like
but walker's so associated with chuck
norris
but anyway but i think that in terms of
if you want to talk about who made the
better
who who's got the next better
opportunity set
up in terms of advancing their career
more between jensen ackles and jared
padalecki
jensen ackles for sure a soldier boy
like that's a perfect transition i think
i don't know much about the soldier boy
character but i'm under the impression
he'll be able to pull this character off
really well
well that seems like it opens the door
for any number of media beyond it even
if he doesn't spend a ton of time on the
show
because they could kill anybody in any
moment but yeah it does seem like that
move
i mean it's a big move to head up be the
star of a network series or whatever but
especially right now it seems like
jensen ackles after doing a season the
boys could go do movies he could go do
whatever
you can do whatever he's got residuals
for life now yeah yeah he's got that cw
money money yeah he's got 15 seasons man
yeah and i would hope like i i honestly
i had a lot of fun with him in my bloody
valentine 3ds so i hope he comes back to
the big screen
i mean let's see how jared patalecki
does for some reason i'm so confident in
jensen apples pulling off the
the soldier boy and the boys and i'm
wondering
like like there was a question earlier
in this stream what is so bad it's good
that it could that it should be re but
what's a so bad it's good movie that
could be remade
and i'm kind of having that nervous
feeling with walker texas ranger
because that is kind of a show that has
some really
terrible moments that it's it often
ventures on
so bad it's good it's [ __ ]
entertaining because of that conan had
the lever
jonah had the walker texas ranger level
because of how ridiculous that show was
and i'm like what are they gonna try to
make like a serious gritty version of
walker texas ranger
yeah where it's all about family and we
love jared
we'll see uh okay written for him i hope
it's good but thank you anissa
lewis thank you lewis hey la lakers 2020
champion welcome to the chat of peter
engeling and kevin sheppard and yara
survivor kim wexler i'm seeing all you
guys here thank you
lewis uh now we've had all your
favorites so what are your absolute
worst
just films that repulse you in every way
there's nothing justifiable for me it's
marquee 1989
evil film avoid what what is the what is
evil
what's the uh category that we're
talking about here refresh my memory
so we're doing absolute worst films is
it worst films
or something more specific let me find
him let me find lewis was in here
earlier right
yeah let me find him i'll find him i'll
find him guys don't worry
don't worry don't i've gone too far i've
gone through all this it's okay you got
this you're gonna do it you're doing so
good yes that was the only time lewis
was here
we can word search for favorite no we're
good all right now all your favorites
just films that repulse you in every way
worst movies that repulse me in every
way
uh you know i haven't seen the human
centipede um
i i wanted to i put it on and then i was
like 20 minutes in
and before anything happened and i was
like can't do it
my mind would not let me go there
my mind was like i just don't want to
experience this i like i'm i'm not gonna
i'm not i'm not gonna do this i'm gonna
i'm gonna feel sick because i'm not
gonna get out my
i know my mind and my mind will not be
able to get that image out of my head
just just seeing it so uh yeah i i don't
i i just wouldn't expose myself to it
and that's fair
yeah especially [ __ ] related stuff you
know [ __ ] vomit stuff oh no not my thing
so yep that one i have repulsed
with something
uh but for some reason the old boy
ending is the one that oh have you seen
old boy i have not
the ending the old boy that that did
a number on me i could not believe what
i was watching
that [ __ ] i now i'm really excited to
check it out i've heard it's in
extreme see with no detail
kevin and the shepherd in the chat is
talking about tusk
and i you know like tusk is nowhere near
as disturbing as i think
people might have thought it to be it's
gross it's icky
um but it's also kind of funny yeah have
you seen tusk
yeah yeah yeah tusca i think is actually
to me i actually love that movie i think
it's twisted but it's like there is an
element where you're like yeah this is a
very
very dark comedy it's ridiculous yeah
yeah yeah exactly and it's it's kevin
smithy
in a way that like red state isn't as
much yeah you know like yeah
i'm trying to think of a movie that
someone said jingle all the way
that is i mean the behavior of these two
dads
um but uh no i'm trying to think
because uh something that like i haven't
had to turn anything off because i was
so repulsed
watching human centipede 2 was the last
time i
remember physically actually
involuntarily being like i'm gonna watch
this kind of through fingers right now
um but i i like that
uh i mean i have a copy of a serbian
film
uncut to some degree that i
i i pass it i see it and every once in a
while i go
one day but not today
and uh so i guess like in theory because
that movie still exists in this bubble
where i
know that every the thing about the
first human centipede
is that that movie really really plays
on your expectation
and is like the second human centipede
is what you think the first one is
and so like the human i mean uh the
serbian film has this quality where i'm
like that sounds even worse than
this so like yeah i i it's the last
movie i can think of right now except
for maybe the original uncut
cannibal holocaust where i would be like
i don't know if i can make it through
this
you know but in terms of like movies
that it's usually not something gross or
or distasteful it's like
the like those parody movies that have
like no
writing in them and are just like look
at this reference and that reference i
kind of hate those on principle just
because you know it's like
you could bother to write five not
clever but at least you tried jokes or
we could just do
this for 90 minutes and waste a bunch of
time and money
so like those things upset me more um i
think the most recent re
new release in the last few years that
really i hated the most recent one would
probably have to be red sparrow
i did not like that that one gave me a
report like i find this movie really
repulsive
yeah i don't like the way this movie
handled itself at all
but thank you lewis for the question
yeah the agoraphobic fanboy just wanted
to congratulate greg on old time radio
and his engagement so happy and excited
wishing the best
well thank you agoraphobic fanboy it's
been a while since i've heard your name
in here
thank you i really appreciate that it
means a lot it's gonna be a long time
coming
and uh there's actually what's funny is
i actually have a another film i wrote
that's way further along
and i already signed a contract with a
studio and i haven't even made a video
about that
dude get ready for a film announcement
every two months that one's like
way further along and all we are is just
in the casting process
now so i i i i'm just so
more waiting the day i'm on set for that
i'll just be like hey
look this is happening you know but
that's
uh i don't know i didn't have i'm trying
to keep that one video that old-time
radio one just focused on that
so i didn't want to mention that one but
thank you thank you agoraphobic fanboy
yeah cornell wilson
gentlemen really big fan do you think
ben affleck's batman should have a
rounded off story in movies or an hbo
max series
i personally thought he was amazing and
deserves a proper story arc
as good as batman t-a-s
uh yes i do think i
do think that ben affleck
i think at this point just because
there's already gonna be the batman with
robert pattinson
i feel like if you wanted to continue
the ben affleck batman it would be
better on hbo max
just so we don't get too confused i
don't know this kind of seems like
like over overdoing it when you if you
have like
two running batman franchises in the
cinemas
i think if you have one in the theaters
and one on hbo max so you get two
very different versions undoubtedly i
think that would be pretty cool
because i feel like the matt reeves
because originally when matt reeves was
doing
the uh batman wasn't ben affleck
originally like attached for a while
to still do it i think so like he he
stepped down from the director
and he hadn't officially signed away
from doing batman
so i and then they obviously went a
wildly different direction and
i i kind of feel like ben affleck's
batman would be better for it and
especially because the snyder cuts going
there now
so like having the home for that
universe to continue existing
i feel like ben affleck's batman would
probably be better for
for that absolutely like in terms of
like cinemas and
one for a show yeah yeah i mean i
thought again two bad mans you can't
really [ __ ] about that am i right it's
batman
it's hard to [ __ ] about that and
especially with gotham pd having trouble
now it would be nice to have like
something just just
to look forward to i mean like i could
take it or leave it
personally and for me i think it'll
depend on
how much i like the snyder cut of
justice league
because uh you know i mean his character
like i liked him fine in bvs and
i think his character as it came out in
the theatrical cut of justice league is
different um so right now i'm still in
that point of like
i hope he does a great job in justice
league and if i love that then yeah i
would love to see him at least maybe
do something that's like his own batman
wrap up
because so many people do love his
portrayal and i think it is one that
you know kind of similarly to henry
cavill like i think there's just a fan
uh aura of like this needs to kind of
have a stamp on it or some kind of way
that we can let it go in a positive way
you know
um wait there's people are saying
there's two fl yeah exactly so joe
mayberry is saying it correctly like
there's two flashes one in the movies
and one on tv and that's what i'm saying
is you put
ben affleck's on tv yeah and then and
then you put robert pattinson in the
in the in the theaters yeah but i do
feel like ben affleck's batman deserves
a wrap up but if it's going to happen in
flash point it happens in flashpoint
but it would be cool what happened to
your hat it got [ __ ] hot in here
really hot and that's what happens when
we livestream it it gets hot and then
about like but do you
not want to see what's going on
underneath all this black right here
everything it's a shower required
rippling moment orgasm-inducing
muscle all right here we go um i still
don't
okay alan tan i still don't get how
tenant inverted bullets work
allentown we really appreciate the super
chat john and i are not the ones to
explain this to you because i honestly
don't get it either
google it but it was cool to look it's
cool in the trailers
cool man it's neat uh let's see here
mark mark thalamus thanks again buddy
for being here
nostalgia is a wonderful thing have you
ever loved
something you watched as a kid then
watched as a grown up and felt
completely let
down you know i had an experience with
one that's probably going to be pretty
controversial that happened very
recently for me
so i'm glad to say this late into the
live stream
because okay all right here's the movie
i'm gonna tell you guys this is like
this is considered a cinema great
oh no some might call a cinema classic
i loved it growing up i really did
and then the other day i was like hey
babe i want to show you
this is really i haven't seen it since i
was a kid
but it's so cool even nolan referenced
it
for his inspiration for many scenes and
how to
do a construct the script for the dark
knight
do you know what movie this is heat it's
heat
she's got a green ass
i watched heat the other day like a few
days ago
and i was like why is this movie nowhere
near as cool or as good as i remember to
be
i feel like it's way too long it's not a
shot it's
this i remember thinking like there's
something weird about some of the
framing where it feels very stretched
out in certain scenes
i'm like al pacino just so over the top
de niro is still
so good but it's just nowhere near
near as cool as i it's yeah
like i don't care about as much and i'm
kind of bored i feel like this drags out
so yeah there's something about heat
where i'm like it's still good
it's not terrible um it's still and i
can see why people
love it still but for me
when i was watching it i was like this
isn't as great as i remember to be
but no see that's what i mean there's a
lot of people a lot of people in this
chat who
like i expected that you guys most i'd
say 99
of people are going to disagree with me
on this for me and there's this really
obvious part that we started cracking up
at and then we slowed it down
where this guy is is al pacino stunt
double this isn't why
i have the issue with the film it's just
a funny moment where al pacino stunt
double
you tackle someone in the apartment and
if you go frame by frame
you see the stunt double tackle a guy
and
look right in the camera and he has like
this little smile on his face when he
does it
yes that's me mom
[Laughter]
you catch my my cameo but no a lot of
people really love it and
uh i'm thinking of ending things haven't
seen that yet kevin shepard this is your
third time asking but thanks for the
question mark lee
do you have one john i mean probably the
thing i watched most as a kid
that i was all about for a while and
i've probably talked about this on
patreon in the past but but yeah
that i was all about that lost in space
movie with matt leblanc
i thought he especially was so
cool in that movie and it has not aged
incredibly well
and uh there were a lot of movies that i
watched every day from
stretches of time as a kid that are
still pretty good
but that one is not among though mando
reaction is being edited right now in
fact
i mean hopefully we got some super chats
and stream laps to go through we will
not leave until we're done
but i do got to start working on the
review and thumbnail
those thumbnails take me like an hour
and a half to put together a [ __ ]
reaction one making sure it hasn't been
sent to me back all right yeah so we're
we're working on uh
it's being edited right now we hired
someone to do that so i figured we'll
just go live in the meantime
um but yeah like hopefully around 4 30
we should really start wrapping things
up but we don't also want to give
quality answers
that's right um mckenna real
not like that fake mckenna
congratulations greg
i was wondering are you excited about
tom holland's new movie
cherry i can't wait for the trailer to
come out and today is my 20th birthday
and i love you guys hey happy birthday
mckenna
sorry it took us so long to get around
to your question really appreciate it
happy birthday and thank you for the
congratulations and yeah
the cherry movies that's the one with
the russo brothers on it am i right
about that yeah
of course i'm excited for it yeah i
think tom hall's an amazing actor and uh
you know he's he's got such amazing
charisma he does
yeah he's just this is an incredible
charismatic guy no matter what he's
doing
it's unstoppable and uh yeah if he's
gonna be in um
if he's gonna be in uh whatever whenever
that trailer comes out
of course we're gonna react to it yeah
it's gonna be the new end game
yeah tom holland man he's the [ __ ] and i
appreciate that mckenna reel means a lot
heck yeah the super reviewer
20th birthday where are you from mckenna
uh hey john
greg check out editor's cut from
spider-man 3 the super reviewer
appreciate the suggestion okay you know
screenshot it
is it a better as a potential which
editor's cut
yeah many editors in this world
but hey if it's better i'll take it rio
mckee
uh what superhero in the mcu do you want
to see
have their own video game oh you know
what
it might have to be the punter
[Laughter]
yeah i think the punisher would be a
dope one i mean it would never get made
if you do like the spider-man marvel gta
marvel's gta games it would be cool to
see him
or you just well he doesn't have super
powers so it might just be like some
other video game
should be a shooter max payne or
something but uh it would be
it would be pretty sweet to see him in
there especially if you have john
bernthal the mocap for him i think that
would be a great
a great one but a cool daredevil one
would be pretty awesome too
uh i think doctor strange would make for
a pretty cool game
uh i want a lifestyle and cooking game
with daryl thor's roommate
there are so many kinds of video games
that you could have you can have it be
like a sims where like you build his
office
you build his house you try and like
level him up and have him have a good
life and then occasionally thor comes in
and ruins it you gotta like fix it
you know make it like one of those
lifestyle maintenance games you see yosh
srivasta in the chat is saying they
really need to make a good superman game
out of all superheroes and yes that is
so
true it seems like the one you should be
able to pull off
uh but they just don't seem to be able
to do it
you know like the flagship superhero
deserves his own
great game yeah i think but a guardians
of the galaxy movie might be fun
i don't know i think the more the
singular focus ones are better like
someone suggested i'm sorry i'm not
catching your comment right now someone
should just suggested iron man right now
um but iron man uh was like
some people thought that he was the best
one out of the avengers in the avengers
to play as so maybe a solo one would be
cool
and they also have the iron man vr the
punisher come on
marvel's never going to do that no when
they do it it'd be awesome
okay and imagine the arcade version
where you actually get the gun
controllers
it was so sweet to play [ __ ] like a
vr version of sure time crisis
vr oh my god that'd be so sweet
yeah dragon soldier oh thank you for the
question rumiki by the way
dragon soldier take it away jon hey guys
it's always great to hear and see you
both do you have any advice to keep
motivation
up for screenwriting my adhd keeps
eating away at me
you have a whole lot of experience with
this sir yes
uh motivation to keep up because it can
be
difficult that and sometimes it affects
the
the quality of my energy level in a
video on the channel oftentimes because
most of the time when i when i write
it's usually late at night because
that's
the best time i have to do it um but
my advice for it you know what i would
start at just one spot there's a bunch
of things i could say
but one of the main things i was
diagnosed with adhd too and
one of the main things that helps me out
is like yes beyond medi
meditating absolutely does but
journaling um
one thing i learned from the a book
called the artist's way
uh which this is sounding like the most
pretentious answer but it's so true
is the stream of consciousness
journaling and i advise this for anyone
like
just not even if you want to write like
this really just helps with clearing
thoughts and
you just do you just commit yourself to
either handwriting or typing but i
prefer handwriting
to writing three pages straight of just
whatever thoughts come to mind doesn't
matter what
don't think don't judge just whatever
comes to mind
and you just write three straight pages
of doing it
and for some reason i notice whenever i
do that like this is
the first chapter of the book and
whenever i do that it makes the world of
difference whenever i write
like just getting it all out there not
really thinking you're just going with
your feelings and like a lot of times
when i started that journaling process
it's usually something like
i feel bored i don't want to do this my
hand hurts i want to go away i want to
sleep
it's just like random stuff and
eventually my thought process starts
clearing up because i'm getting junk out
of the way
and then eventually they stopped being
just stream of consciousness good night
chelsea brown chelsea
so yeah that's my main advice that's
great advice
actually no the i mean in general those
morning pages or whenever you do them
those stream of consciousness pages are
very helpful
i think for a lot of things absolutely
um smack
gaming smart gaming
top three scorsese movies and shout out
from the air force in new mexico
whoa what the [ __ ] what's up dude i hope
to everyone
that's great i hoped everyone enjoyed
a very weird thanksgiving it was a weird
one indeed
um let's see here uh top three scorsese
movies
i mean goodfellas departed
and i would have to probably say cape
fear oh those are my three
three favorite uh scorsese films
yeah yeah those are the ones i would i
can re-watch the most and just have a
ball when i'm watching them
okay yeah ours are this is probably a
fair amount of crossover i would say
yeah
the the one different it's a good fella
is a
shutter island for me and probably cape
fear is so great
and cape fear i always associate with
you too so like
from like back in the day when we made a
cape fear parody that's lost
yeah that was a good one yeah that and
that movie is
like and as a remake too like that
that's a really well done movie see
sojin choi in the chat said taxi good
fellas and raging bull which are usually
the go-to answers i think for scorsese
and those are all great films
uh for me it is uh it was it's
definitely those three
as my personal picks um let's see here
but yeah kim webster the screen of
consciousness journal if that's where
you're writing down just go be raw
honest
what matters is you don't give in to
actions but you know having thoughts or
feelings is one thing
um anissa have you all ever heard of
cinema rules
it's a fairly new channel on the two but
they remind me of y'all but british
check them out perhaps one day we will
thank you anissa
or perhaps we will just screenshot here
yeah
let's let's let's check them out first
and then destroy them
um okay let's see here now just as uh
just as a john he put the super chats
away now we have some more super chats
and stream laps to go through but i did
want to say just because we have to get
back to work on
um while our editor is coming up the
reaction because it usually takes like
two to three edits
uh so it's like testing out edits
because what ends up happening is
and every reactor goes through this so i
don't feel like we're alone on this
is it usually takes two to three edits
because they constantly get blocked and
we added most of the things ourselves
but for mandalorian we have our buddy
who's like
way better at getting the tv show ones
up than than not than we are
uh so but i do have some work to do for
the mandalorian
that i have to be like i have to make
sure this footage gets to him the review
and i also got to get the thumbnails
ready uh beforehand so
appreciate everyone who's contributed to
the super chats and our stream labs
but uh we would appreciate it if uh we
stopped the contributions at this point
so we can
properly finish off the ones that are
here uh
so far right now but really do
appreciate it your support means a hell
of a lot
um because you know we also like to give
take our time with a good amount of
these questions like to address you each
see kim wex was talking about um what
you may call it silence
that's the one that you really do love i
do like you know what yeah i mean that
that might not make my top three but i
do feel like that's a really underrated
scorsese flick i that that yeah i know
some catholics who
hate the fact that he stopped that i
mean there's a whole debate there about
like step on this crucifix of christ
yeah and it's like this really it seems
and
you know from like a person who's not a
devoted catholic i was just like
step on the [ __ ] crucified yeah come
on man
but then you talked to some devoted
catholics they're like no
movie lost me there and i'm like damn
that is that's the power of that movie
right yeah
yeah it raises it raises some
fascinating philosophical debates
especially by that point
i can't talk to you about your beliefs
man that's that that's that's a great
one
yeah seek amanda will be up tomorrow yes
you have our word no matter what no
matter
what no matter what all right we're
gonna finish off the last of our stream
labs
and our uh super chips and our super
chats too
uh but yeah kartik you are the last one
for the day on that one
but let's go to our stream labs john set
us up you're the best
right all right and i would say the omen
19786 and i actually like the paranormal
activity movies for the most part
i i get a lot of crap now but
uh yeah okay markster says about silence
i'm the same about the crucifix and i'm
an idiot
all right so scroll down yeah so we did
christian alante last
yeah so scared james 1999.
chuffed for you greg red dead redemption
show by the way
versus movie i would say ooh um so
scared jared knight thank you so scared
just for you greg great to see a joy
bringer
find his wife and best friend for the
game of life
top five access movies in no particular
order
gents he's saying scrooged
trading places home alone die hard and
national lampoon's exodus vacation here
love you both i would say
i would say elf
i would also say lethal weapon
more than die hard ah
i don't like eight crazy nights
but it's on this list anyway i haven't
seen a shop around the corner
it's a good one what is the one with
uh who plays dorothy judy judy julie
garland uh uh
meet me in st louis me and san luis is a
good one yeah
that's a good one that's a great one and
that covers like the the
gamut of the winter falls before
christmas i think is way more of a
christmas movie than a halloween movie
so i would say nightmare before
christmas
yeah and you know what shouts out to
kurt russell's christmas chronicles
because that movie
is [ __ ] hilarious i don't care what
anyone says
hey all right a sequel for a reason
because critics might hate it
it's a funny ass movie i don't care and
i've heard the sequel's
bonkers night before is a pretty
underrated christmas movie i gotta give
it to you
yeah yeah
and i have been considering forest gum
by the way but john please what are your
favorite christmas movies
uh i would go yeah definitely like elf
uh it's a wonderful life
charlie brown christmas uh uh the grinch
cartoon
and uh and yeah i think me and st louie
like it's not
i'll go with white christmas just to say
something different
see eric and eric watch olivia
introduced me to meet me in st
louis yeah it's a great movie it's a
great movie thank you salsa jay
and speaking of eric eric was here oh my
god eric we got a hundred bucks
here oh my gosh eric you just got back
from dinner
just got back from dinner i need to rush
over to give greg and john
a big stream live contribution i hope
you didn't you dude i hope you didn't
deprive a waiter
eric's a funny ass [ __ ] like you're
talking with him on the discord
especially the other day him and anissa
and bradley oh
eric is so funny so funny um
sorry for being late my ubereats had
arrived no questions
yet i thought you were eating dinner
with your family i don't start drinking
until 7 p.m
john no day drinking for the alki lol
oh that's good so excited to watch the
next man to lauren with you all tomorrow
i finished all the clone wars he was
messaging me about this
he's like do you think i could finish
clone wars before the next mandalorian
video comes out and i'm like i don't
think so man a lot of seasons said [ __ ]
he did it
um and season four episode seven of
rebels onto the question would you want
to see live-action movies of either of
these or even a mandalorian movie
i think it would be pretty [ __ ] sweet
if you do
all of the mandalorian uh
all the seasons of mandalorian and then
you end it with like a two and a half
hour movie yeah like a big
giant centerpiece movie yeah i mean you
see the power of that show
like mandalorian hasn't been trending
that big
but today and even yesterday before it
even came out it's been non-stop
trending yeah not just the mandalorian
but like
care like ezra ahsoka i guess not even
in it but like
yeah all these people and i think it
would be pretty [ __ ] sweet to get
that hey sarah campbell welcome
hey happy to see you uh yeah i would
definitely
love to see uh i don't think there's any
clone wars movies that are necessary
but i do think that if you already got
like an animated movie out of it
i think if you end in mandalorian with a
movie i would love that
that would be pretty that would be
awesome i agree i think getting like a
darth maul origin movie would be great
oh i that's a character whose origin i'd
be interested in like really watching
that especially after how they reshaped
his character in clone wars and rebels
like
it's crazy because you know you watch
him in phantom menace and like he's cool
but he's an action figure yeah but then
you watch him and like clone wars and
rebels like damn this guy
is he just steals the scenes whenever he
is on screen and like in the clone wars
finale just
having him and ahsoka go toe to toe with
each other
yes it was wonderful wonderful
heck yeah um but anyway yeah thank you
eric that's a great question and happy
to have you here and i hope you start
drinking soon
yeah it's got to be seven where you are
right oh my gosh so when we started this
stream
fleb doran had uh started alien and now
he's
just finished alien i'm back fleb is
saying okay he's got an
opinion all right i'm back alien was
great worth the hype we are living now
in the era of superhero movies what
old movie arrow would you love to or
could be the trend again
i would love to see more early slapstick
comms or
mom and i love laurel and hardy films
me and my buddy plan on to binge the
harry potter films in december
because nothing says more christmas
think you know [ __ ] christmas harry
potter yeah
i don't know they always make me think
of christmas time man except for home
alone which is my tradition what other
christmas films should i binge next
month don't say die hard i'd say do the
lethal weapon movies
do the lethal weapon watch fat man top
it all off with fat man
eric has started drinking
congratulations hey that's what i like
to hear
what era what i would love to see more
early slapstick comps i don't know about
slapsticks but i would like to see
um my mind kind of went to i want to see
more serious actors do some funny movies
yeah like christian bale really do a
comedy dicaprio
really do a comedy how crazy would it be
if we got daniel day-lewis to come out
of retirement
to star in a judd apatow movie or
something like that you know
i i want this like how great would that
be get them all to
that's kind of what i want to see more
and i felt like we were starting to get
hints of that
like james franco is a serious actor
then he goes and does pineapple express
things like the apatow crew
uh channing tatum was doing like some
more serious films are trying to be more
serious they need this 21 jump street
things like that and i kind of that's
kind of where my mind went i don't know
what era
of film or trend but yeah i'd say that
there's
it's been a long time there's been like
a damn good rom-com i feel like netflix
usually
good ones are hulu but a big theatrical
one
these days yeah but i think rom-coms are
weirdly better suited for streaming
services because
you know it's netflix and chill or you
don't know you stay home you cuddle up
you watch a movie it's romantic
yeah so yeah i feel like the the
i don't know i mean this is kind of
broad but i feel like the film noir
detective genre would be a nice one to
have come back in a swing especially in
a time that we live in where like
facts are always under review
and there's so much deceit and there's
so much like
it's a time in which there's a lot put
on persona
facts and perspectives and i feel like
uh the film noir you know like the
private eye type but with
having to just those themes of having to
like form uneasy alliances with various
people and solve mysteries and whatnot
like
i feel like every once in a while a
neo-noir or something pops up but i feel
like that would be cool
or that i i really wish that anybody
other than disney remaking one of their
previous movies could get like a big
lavish studio musical off the ground i
missed that genre
uh but yeah i just want to see adam
driver be a comedy
yes adam driver comedies well you know
he showed up on last week tonight so it
could happen
all right here we go oh he finally did
he fight yeah last week tonight
watch the season the season finale all
right these are the last of
our uh super chats yes sir and then
we'll do a quick speed round in the
comments but yeah all right
cool yeah all right here we go
here we go solid sanity seven what
mit thank you solid sanity seven what
medieval era movie do you have the most
fun
with versus which one do you think is
the best constructed
hmm i love the movie excalibur
it's yeah i was going to say i love
excalibur when i think a medieval movie
my mind goes there i think
the mo the one i have the most fun with
is army of darkness yeah
yeah i think that's the perfect set of
answers
uh i'll i'll throw out i it's arthurian
but you know
i liked uh antoine fuqua's director's
cut of king arthur i think that movie's
uh underrated but yeah
like it's hard to be because excalibur
has all the production values but also
like this sort of dreamy mythical
qualities
and then army of darkness is just the
best
yes hell yeah uh probably will not read
those chaos walking books
just put that out there gonna read them
all right before i read dune
thanks for the question solid sanity
i've never gone on that one before
mckenna reel's back
uh mckenna real thank you i just want to
say thank you both because especially
greg
um not john john can go to hell john can
suck a dick
i don't know why i'm taking that's what
i'm taking why she said all that that's
what i'm taking so
sorry she went there it's it's a
signifier of my being behind
no i was projecting oh
oh it doesn't actually say that oh my
bad i just kind of agreed with you
i just sort of agree when you say things
it's okay it was my fault you said that
let's see what she said
it is comforting hearing you talk about
mental health stuff i'm sorry
i'm not laughing at you i just made a
really [ __ ] up joke and
you have such a sweet comment here i'm
sorry
this is such a nice sense of your thing
this is how we do i really appreciate
that
uh it is comforting hearing you talk
about mental health stuff because
sometimes it is hard for me personally
and your connection to your viewers is
so genuine
is it is it josh
kim outrageous original eric horseman
peter england
nightshade holloway nicole harris kim
wexler sojin choi melissa todd
is it genuine outrageous origami is it a
genuine comment below let us know
comment turtle movie fan if you feel
look
genuine hit the like button hit the like
button
and then subscribe and unsubscribe or
resubscribe turn on all notifications
uh i know i really do appreciate that
you know i don't try to
like always go down mental health
discussions i like to try to refocus it
constantly back if especially if we do
something like
if there's like one upload or two
uploads a week that are not
film related in some way i'm like now
let's bring it back
let's bring it back let's bring it back
um but talking about mental health i
noticed that that discussion usually
comes out of me
during uh other people's videos like if
they're interviewing us somehow it comes
up
and i feel like people shouldn't be shy
to talk about it uh
my family's not the the best at talking
about it uh but
i feel like with a lot of my friends and
especially out in california i feel like
people who go to therapy
the numbers are way higher than they
were when i first started going to
therapy or when john first started going
like
there's a time where you're still like i
don't want to tell people about this but
but now it's like it's such a common
thing it's less of a stigma anymore and
i really do encoura i really do think
it's important and
um also to not let anything that
diagnosis
whatever diagnosis you get define
you and i think that's like the main
thing i would always encourage for
people
is oftentimes we can use our diagnosis
like i've been diagnosed with three main
things i've talked about
ptsd adhd type 2 bipolar and
those come with a lot of symptoms but
but my point is
is to not let those things hinder you
and to
find ways to embrace it if you can or
like some people try to just
like some people i think are under the
impression that you have to get rid of
them
uh but there's a way to kind of you have
to be developing of self-awareness to
maintain and be aware of what can
trigger things to come up
and that's probably the biggest thing is
being aware of not giving in to those
things i think whatever thoughts and
feelings you have are okay
be okay with that at the same time you
know that doesn't mean you have to act
upon it or something like especially
when you're doing a thing like youtube
you know it's a
very easy for someone like me who is
very very prone to get triggered
by a lot of things that happen on
youtube comments or whatever
dealing with math my mind is not the
healthiest when it comes to it so every
once in a while i have to delete social
media
i have to be very adamant about not
reading youtube comments it's very
important for me sometimes to do that
because
you know [ __ ] with someone like me yeah
then everyone said i go back to it you
know
and uh yes so i would say
thank you thank you mcmahon i don't
think that's weird
no i think that's a really transition
now i think that's a really good thing
to be
to a good point to make because that's
been a big part of
my recent journey of life is recognizing
those things that like you
you know it's like if you receive a
diagnosis like that it's part of a map
that's helping you understand your mind
but i feel like
i've definitely done this and i think a
lot of people you you take it very as a
personal element of your core being and
you identify with it in a way that
isn't actually quite as helpful and and
yeah it's partly about
recognizing that yeah this thing is a
part of my journey it's a part of me
um but it's not me it's not the entirety
of me and it's you know an aspect that i
can be aware of and
behave in you know the face of and get
yourself a good woman
or man right olivia
right olivia damn it olivia where's my
steak
bring me my beer
oh that i hope you're doing well mckenna
hope you're doing well thank you
thank you that's really sweet um it
really is thank you
heroes fan productions hmm i may have
missed it
raccadillo we never plan our streams in
advance properly
not yeah today was like let's do it
today
today yeah there was like a brief moment
that we we would think about this and
then today i was like yeah that still
seems okay let's do it
anise is pissed why why did you what is
this drama you guys are getting into
don't don't anissa what's wrong do i
need to hop on the discord again
why are you pissed eric tell us all
heroes fan productions
i may have missed it but what did you
guys think of chapter 13 of the
mandalorian
well uh the reaction will be up tomorrow
and no it's our we already put it up put
it up
can't see it anymore uh what i wanted to
say was that
okay non-spoilery other than the fact
that everyone knows the circus out so
i'm gonna say that
i think that rosario dawson gives a
different take on ahsoka tano
and i really really liked it a hell of a
lot
it feels different more mature more
reserved
i really loved it and i also think the
episode itself of the mandalorian
was pretty [ __ ] incredible
the capturing both samurai and western
tones
fused into one beautifully captured
horror undertone episode
and a lot of big ass information yeah
and no nice i haven't opened the package
yet
tomorrow for sure um now that we
announced it and just want to make good
time to carve it out because sometimes
with your video
these unboxings anisa were there for 25
minutes
sometimes we sit down we're like oh this
would be quick i love it uh
i love it uh like i love when you send
us stuff so i want to make sure we have
like a good half hour dedicated we want
to honor the work you put into and have
energy for it yeah
so but uh yeah i think the mandalorian
next latest episode is one of the best
episodes of the season i'm not just
saying that
it is really one of the best of the
season yeah really great film craft
really great
intriguing action it's got all the
cereal stuff that you want but a cool
episode like it's everything that
i love about the mandalorian so hell
yeah to that
keep an eye out for the reaction uh mr
vaju thank you congrats on the
engagement you hear that olivia
uh olivia and my girlfriend could pass
four sisters by the way
we should double date mr ivaji absolute
have you seen ted lasso yet love that
show unfortunately haven't
unfortunately haven't but i think olivia
and your girlfriend should fight mud
wrestling fight
let's get it going yeah odds are olivia
will win she'll take yours down mr vaju
that's where i take super chats
just a mud wrestling fight we'll project
a ted lasso episode in the background
just for you
appreciate that though mr major love you
buddy um
ulysses back at it uh it's me again any
advice about doing reaction videos i'm
planning on doing some next year maybe
some time around the release of stranger
things four
well if you're covering tv shows those
are a bit of a [ __ ] all right you want
to keep it under 10 minutes worth
you got to be really mindful of that
audio it's really hard
but in terms of doing reactions yourself
i would say
the the advice i give any guest who
comes on this channel
the main thing i tell them and i believe
it's in the john campbell documentary
is whatever you're feeling internally
just let it out externally
you know like don't be shy about it
sometimes people will give you a crap
of like do you really do this and you
buy yourself like people say [ __ ] like
that
at the same time sometimes yeah you do
do that when you're by yourself that's
part of the point of it
like at the same time though i think you
know like if you keep talking over the
video people might get annoyed by that
they want you to experience it so the
advice i always get people
if they're doing reactions like because
i want people to just be themselves
that's it no matter who they are if
they're a guest here just be themselves
and if i say too much they'll get caught
up and overthink it because they're like
how do i behave but so i just say
whatever you're thinking feeling
internally just let it out
and it's kind of a fun expression
practice of like this little feeling now
i'm showing it it's kind of a silly
thing but
yeah that's what i would say heck yeah
coming right from the master to your
ears
the master reactions eric
john take this one away eric of the
newer generation of
horror directors who do you prefer
robert eggers mike flanagan ari astor
jordan peele james one andy muschietti
or andre
of riddle
dude i'm a mike flanagan guy honestly i
think out of all these guys i i'm
like it's it's a toss-up but it's jordan
peele's only done two movies
and michael is a pretty consistent guy
and his style of horror really is
the kind of horror i love
psychologically driven character horror
but jordan peels got the entertain
jordan peel and james one have the
entertainment
value um but i i would say mike flanagan
on as a
on a very personal level flanagan
i think yeah fla flanagan in terms of
flanagan or james one and
the mannequin with the flannigan with
the man again back out again
flanagan and james won i think for just
consistency and
mastery it's hard to beat either of them
i think in this
particular list i mean i get excited to
a degree
for all of these choices but uh i think
uh jordan peel yeah is it's just like
he's got
the entertainment value that i could see
coming out of a james wan film but at
the same time he's got the attention to
character and tone and precision that
like uh uh mike flanagan
or even like uh maybe not quite down the
historical rabbit holes of robert eggers
or nariaster but you know
he seems to kind of bring a lot of these
together in a way so yeah like
on track record maybe not so much but i
really love
the splash of of aura of his work
i mean they're all great directly
they're all great these are all [ __ ]
amazing directors i'm not a swimmer with
andre overdoll
um they're all great and robert eggers
and ari astor i think are like extremely
bold
oh yeah and what they choose to put in
their movies like
those are two directors there who are
like well give a [ __ ]
i'm just doing my thing i'm doing what i
want to do
i don't care i don't care if this makes
you feel
awful i don't care if you don't get what
i'm doing like
this is this is my thing yeah yeah yeah
uh so yeah i would i would definitely
like robert eggers especially his knack
for dialogue is
wildly impressive yes it is it's like
reading a [ __ ] hp lovecraft book when
you like
watch one of his movies all those shouts
out go watch scary story shouts out to
andre overdoll
scary stories and troll hunter both good
so
um mark leach what films that seem
are that scene are less known or
underrated do you find yourself
recommending to people to a minor kiss
kiss bang bang and colorado speaking if
you want to see that
speaking of hp lovecraft yeah color out
of space
and uh yeah i would i constantly
recommend the invitation
drive is another one that i constantly
reckon i feel like drive is not one that
needs to be recommended as much
but invitation is one i constantly
recommend
um and let the right one in funny enough
like all three of these are films that
came up in this live stream already but
let the right one in is one i really
recommend a lot and what did happen to
bradley but yeah
those are those are the ones i recommend
johnny the invitation is definitely one
uh uh less known damn i just had it
uh yeah i mean the invitation is
probably the one i do the most because i
remember when i discovered that and that
was a very sort of
yeah it's not big enough to the point
where everyone would have heard of it
um damn i had a good one but it's it's
gone from my mind and the more i think
about it now the more i'm gonna
fudge that um yeah you know
i would say that no one responds to
anyone hearing the chat melissa someone
responsive melissa would you
uh yes i disagree with you on there
drive is one of my favorite movies of
all time
um oh attack the block is one yeah i i
find myself recommending attack the
block things like that super
uh yeah thanks
thank you mark leach and justin sutton
he's saying thank you justin
congrats on the movie greg really
appreciate that i love anthology horror
what's your favorite outside of trick or
uh my personal favorite is tales from
the crypt
you know i haven't seen any of the tales
from the [ __ ] movies but the season one
show
i did watch that one i made sure to
watch every episode
um not to prep for the
writing the anthology movie but there
was one ep there's one of the ones that
i wrote
like when the idea was pitched to me it
said ec
comics and i was like all right let me
just watch season one of tales from the
crypt
and uh so i bought it and it was i was
like damn this shit's [ __ ] good
and it goes there you know like it's
bold
bold ass [ __ ] so i i i would have to
meet you there on sales in the [ __ ] but
in terms of live-action movies i might
go with creep show
right creep show's hard to beat you know
creep show is a classic and it's
definitely i
it's not like yeah creep show trick or
treat
and you know tales from the crypt seem
to be like the gold standards i do like
vhs too
uh i feel like vhs is kind of hard to
inch into the
true echelon of greats but uh but i
think that one's worth a watch
absolutely yeah tails from the hood go
watch tails from the tails pretty fun
too
yeah tails from hood's fun i like tails
from the hood i do too
travis bryant didn't say anything but
appreciate the super chat dude thank you
for the
love and support kartik sharma
okay so we got kartik sharma here and
niraj here so what we'll do is we'll
combine
these two uh really quick but thank you
kartik i really appreciate it
and rackadio i do see you have one
coming and you will be the last one of
the day
uh kartik do you think tony stark
became meal nor worthy between his snap
and death could holding manure have
saved him like it saved thor and thor
tony stark said his autobiography would
be named cheap trick and
and cheesy one-liner he did and said
exactly that to thanos before snapping
oh how funny
you know it's actually an interesting
question cardig i've never thought about
if tony stark did become male nor worthy
but i would
say my personal opinion
i can't speak for the gods to
decide who is worthy of wielding that
hammer
my take would be yes he did
i would say
yes he definitely didn't yep because it
all comes down to him at that one but he
is the one
reality i would definitely say that
yeah i would say so and uh i did not
know that fact that you said about the
autobiography i never put that together
but thank you for letting me know that
is a fun
question thank you little easter egg uh
niraj
you know i'm gonna do a quick refresher
and this will this should be the last
one i think so
everyone's behaving yourself making sure
because then i would definitely got to
get back to a little bit of extra work
that we got to get done
okay oh man oh [ __ ] we got a couple of
ones here damn okay yeah
we got one all right we gotta do the
rogers in a minute but mysterious
midnight thank you so much
just want to say hello thanks mysterious
midnight hello to you
who the [ __ ] are you how are you tell us
about yourselves like who is this person
that just gave us a large
contribution and super and uh streamlabs
thank you is it is it midnight where you
are right now i appreciate that thank
you
thank you so much it's amazing all right
that's thank you and then here are the
last ones we've got three more to wrap
up
and let's go here okay all righty
niraj if you guys got the golden ticket
like from last action hero which movie
would you like to live in
which movie would i like to live in
[Music]
oh boy what is a fun one let's see yeah
where you would be careful on these
answers [ __ ] people don't think this
through like [ __ ] you say like
star wars or lord of the rings i'm like
yeah that means death impediment
death all right the most it's cool isn't
my look your odds of dying are very
very high yeah uh unless you get like
all the options in the world you know
i want to be forced yoda i want to be an
important central protagonist
a movie world that you would want to
live in
uh um
does that have to be a live actor a
passion of the crest
silence by martin scorsese um
what's the movie that sky high that
would be a good movie
god what is one i want to live in some
some world that's like not too
dangerous uh yeah yeah i don't like this
movie but i guess i would go with the
avatar world
you would want to live there it just
looks so fun this just looks like such a
blasty blast
okay that's fair or charlie in the
chocolate factory the tim burton one
i just want to live in in the chef movie
because look how great all those
sandwiches look man you would just hang
out with john favreau you would talk
about food you would eat food
uh but the indiana jones i guess in the
indiana jones one would be cool
or uh happy death day
god i can't know oh how awful
jesus christ no i'd want to live in the
last action hero world
the world of jingle all the way yes i
want
i just want to be fighting sinbad for a
turbo man ah
ethan holgate uh i don't have any
favorite roger moore bond movies
i've never seen any of the roger moores
i have to get that out of the way but
thank you dude for the cool
super chat glad you didn't risk too much
um rakadio hey guys rackadeer here like
i believe do you guys think the
mandalorian is the best star wars
content to come out
in a long time congrats greg well thank
you racado it means a lot
uh yeah you know i think out of the
live-action ones of the disney series
and i think it is better than the
prequels
i would have to say the mandalorian is
not easily the best thing that disney
has done with star wars
it's surpris like it's funny how you
hate [ __ ] disney
when you watch some of those movies yeah
and then you love what
they let dave filoni and john favreau do
delorean when you watch that goddamn
show
rogue one yeah it's pretty amazing
yeah oh yeah
to me it's a no-brainer yeah it's
definitely the mandalorian 100
because it's also just going back to the
original spirits that inspired the
stories to begin with and not bogging it
i feel like in a weird way they're
showing how to with poise
handle both new and familiar classic
themes
in a way that the movies seem to very
much struggle with
well thank you raccadillo thank you
appreciate it
guys all right thank you so much for
being here let's just do a quick
quick quick few once super quick super
quick in the live stream
and we gotta head out right away ah
let's see here some people like to live
with the indiana jones role he does get
away with a lot that dr
jones true i did like the the lighthouse
[ __ ] weird
oh the succession is a really fun show i
mean it's it's filled with terrible
people but also who are very fun to
watch
some good actors great acting um
[Music]
if he i'm trying to pick something up
and i'm feeling space by talking about
yeah
i feel like we're not seeing eye to eye
on so many of the properties that we're
talking about today
james have you ever walked out of a
cinema viewing there's uh
i've walked out of napoleon dynamite
and hot rod and then later when talking
with friends that very night
i we started laughing thinking about it
and then i went back and watched both of
them in the theaters and laughed my ass
off
those were the kind of comedy it was
totally
totally wrong totally did not measure me
when i walked in and then thinking about
it made me laugh and then i went back
and laughed some more
uh thank you kevin shepard an album to
listen to stadium arcadium by the red
hot chili peppers it's an
epic galactic experience oh yeah
uh it's album time by toddy
have yourself a dance party and uh let's
see here
six feet under there's a good one or
spirit world field guide by asap rock
all right i need to call her editor or
song machine gorillas
but guys thank you so much for being in
the stream this was a fun one a relaxing
one i appreciate it everyone who's
contributing our stream labs and our
super chats
happy hands and i hope you guys have a
wonderful weekend a relaxing one
mandalorian reaction we're working on
right now should be up in the morning
our time if we're
if we play our cards right and we're
able
to get it done if we're able to get it
done uh where
it's not blocked then we bet your ass
it's going live right away in the
morning so
please do keep a look out for that
because i've heard that live streams can
actually sometimes affect
your algorithm algorithm like your
videos that are not live streams
so we took a chance here but thank you
guys
so much thank you for everyone for being
here yeah i will watch shawshank
redemption one day
thank you gonna do a great job best
eating scene the steward in two towers
eating in front of pitman
any scene inside of oh you saw red hot
chili peppers
weren't they supposed to play the
staples center and then i don't know
uh james eisen taylor thank you kim
wexler
sl7 pastor everyone who's been here you
guys nissan
love happy thanksgiving we're thankful
for you
we'll see you guys soon